what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start do not forget to
subscribe to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification Bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos as you guys already know if you
have watched two or more of my lives and
you do not subscribe we have beef okay
beef people
um a couple announcements before we
start the show the first is that we have
two clips channels the first is just
pearly clips and the second is Pearl
daily uh make sure you go subscribe to
both we have two different editors on
those accounts so you get two different
types of Clips the second announcement
is that we have four membership tiers
the first the first lets you be a part
of our live chat the second you get to
be a part of our Discord and our behind
the scenes Vlogs the third you get to
connect with us connect with me on
social media and the fourth you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month a
lot of people you know need help growing
their YouTube channel so I really
recommend that right China right China
I'm good I'm good at helping with
YouTube now she's the best time
also guys they banned my Instagram at
80k
it was so sad yeah but I'm back I'm
almost to 10K so make sure you go follow
my new Instagram hey
um they can't get rid of me just pearly
things one um also go follow my uh fifth
fourth fifth and sixth tick tocks just
pearly things dot five and just pearly
things six
um subscribe okay
if you're a 304 if you're a modern woman
and you want to be a wife sign up for y
to school go subscribe to my channel um
wife School the link to that should be
in the description
um we're almost to 750k sub so make sure
you guys subscribe to the channel like
the video
and all the super chats today are going
towards a camera where you could see
um if someone leaves the podcast you can
see them walk out so
so we want to have like a back end
camera so um yeah the super chats today
are going towards that anyways today we
have a lovely panel so um why don't we
go around everyone say your name your
age your relationship status and a fun
fact about yourself so you start go
around and then we'll do the second row
um so my name is pink Kush and that's
the name that I go by
I
sorry can you repeat the questions I'll
say no your name your age your
relationship status and a fun fact my
name I gave my name for pink Kush
um my age is 25 and my relationship
status is
free agent I would say or free agent and
um the last one a fun fact talked about
myself is that I'm a oh that's too many
um
I can pop my eyes out no you gotta show
us
I want to see you guys for pads I'm kind
of nervous do it do it do it do it do it
oh no
I don't know if everyone okay
hi guys my name is Bex I'm 25 I'm single
and I like to ride horses
oh cool
hello my name is yamuna and a lot of
people call me shorty I am 40 and I am
currently going through a divorce and I
guess the fun fact I would share today
is I have two sons and I home educate
them oh cool
so my name is Cleo I am actually
terrified because I'm 41 and I'm slowly
realizing I might be the oldest person
in the room my uh relationship status is
uh single and the fun fact is I have
both my armpits tattooed
peonies what's with oh the flower the
flower okay yeah yeah oh we're going
this way or that way um you two and then
the second row will go
um I'm Tanya
no no push it cluster there you go okay
so I'm Tanya I'm 24. I'm single
um fun fact I love travel
okay
hey my name is China the my name's voice
good to be back
um I'm a regular guest and I can say it
because Paul said I can say it so I am
I'm gonna shout out the the the the the
chat the chat guys because I know they
show me a lot of love here it's good to
be on the show
um yeah I got me a sweet one you know I
got the sweet because I talk about going
to sweet one and yeah
okay um and then you go and then you go
can go that way around
hi
can you hear me yeah yeah my name's
Stephanie I'm 33 years old
um I am in a relationship
and a fun fact about me is that my
favorite film is Shrek and I know like
an hour of the script
and you could recite it I can recycle
can you recite two lines
um oh my God don't do that to me I'm a
donkey I'm just like
I can actually hear like lines coming
now what did you say I'm a donkey on the
edge
I was the one
yeah I know like just it's just weird he
was like my childhood sweetheart I love
him
when he was the overall when he was here
all the time he was misunderstood like
people like look at his loving heart
like he was just the best he is the best
he's the he's the nice guy
hi my name's sweet juice AKA Misha I'm
28. my relationship status is single and
[Music]
um fun fact
um I've got a larger than life
personality but my social battery is
like running out as we go but yeah
go ahead
um my name is Jasmine Bruce I am 19
years old I my relationship status is
taken and a fun fact about me I released
My First Independent single last month
cool Cadillac should be nice
yeah
I'm Alex
35 years old
and a fun fact about oh no single
fun fact about me is you guys need to go
and check out 100 interviews on YouTube
jeez okay interview coming soon with
pearl let's find out who this person is
the person the person behind the
controversy and the truth to be fair
okay what shaped her how did she become
who she is today
I like it my name is Jessica Cuca
um fun fact I just make r b music that's
pretty much all I do
um and I'm 19 years old and that's
pretty much it relationships oh I'm
single as one can be
um but yeah
okay so I have something to I have guys
have said talking
um I have something to read to you guys
okay
wait today's topic I forgot to say the
topic today's topic is can modern women
be men so in the last 25 years women
have made strides in management and
Leadership positions in the workplace as
of 2022 women represent 35 percent of
leadership positions in companies in the
U.S and 33 in the UK women also make up
27 of the seats in the current U.S
Congress and 30 35 percent of MPS in the
UK Parliament Studies have shown that
organizations with a diverse mix of male
and female leaders tend to outperform
those that don't by 30 percent while
this may sound like nothing new but like
nothing while this may sound like
nothing but good news a study from UCLA
surveyed 60 000 professionals and found
that women even those who were managers
themselves were more likely to to want a
male boss than a female one the
participants explained that female
bosses are emotional catty or [ __ ] men
preferred male bosses too but by a much
smaller margin than female participants
did a much smaller survey by UCLA of Law
Firm staff secretaries paralegals Etc
nearly all of whom were women resulted
in not one saying that she would that
she or he would prefer to work for a
female law partner the study showed that
females in the legal profession that
reported to a female boss showed more
symptoms of distress including trouble
sleeping and headaches when compared to
working for a man Gallup completed a
survey that gave a holistic view of this
phenomenon the study found that almost
40 percent of women preferred male
leadership as compared to 26 percent of
men when asked would you prefer would
you prefer to work for a female or a
male boss the responses of those that
preferred male leadership leadership can
be summed up as followed mail bosses are
more receptive towards new ideas and
allowed execution with minimal
interference they're a lot nicer and
less emotional they have less drama and
are less jealous of their better looking
counterparts they recognize and applaud
commitment and dedication and are more
direct to deal with and willing to wade
into disagreements amongst subordinates
also statistics from the workplace
bullying Institute have shown that 80 oh
God that's so bad that 80 percent of the
time women bully other women while at
work
if more women prefer male leadership how
is there a patriarchy of the modern
workplace is it time to recognize and
recognize the toxic matriarchy thoughts
question for the woman
what has your overall experience been
with female leadership compared to male
leadership in your industry
um so
starting here and then go around if this
if you've never had a like both genders
as bosses you can say that too
um well I've experienced both a male and
female management but I'll say I've
experience one female management G to
Blackmail
um
female I would say they're more direct I
feel like sometimes Mel um
management or stuff they just tend to
have like a more standoffish approach
whereas females were more
straightforward maybe they're more like
engaging really I would say it was okay
it was good it was a good experience but
there can be a bit of like that woman to
woman kind of matching it's like kind of
how men have that
Alpha kind of situation going on I feel
like that can occur at times and
obviously being a female you know we're
very like intuitive at times we're like
is she trying to you know trying to play
games
playing My Mentor but you know yeah
nothing too intense like very mediocre
okay what about you two
um I've had by if I've had a woman
manager once and I prefer having a male
manager just because they're less
emotional I feel like in terms of
leadership
I trust men more and I prefer a man to
lead and a lot of older women not all
but a lot are a bit jealous of younger
women especially if they look nice or if
they have a lot of talent and sometimes
it makes them wish that they were young
again so yeah I just prefer
I prefer
um men like I trust male leadership
foreign
so I'm really lucky I've only had one
female boss and she was actually a very
good friend of mine as well and we
worked wonderfully together
um I'm 40 and she's I think 12 years
older than me and I think if you have a
good working
understanding relationship with the
woman that you're working with it can be
a really wonderful thing
um then I've worked for many many males
the majority of whom have
been inappropriate I guess at some point
like not physically but just more like
[Music]
um
it's like comments something flirty
flirty and you know um suggestive you
know maybe provocative inappropriate did
you ever feel like you got like better
like you moved up faster because they
were flirting with you yeah I did and
actually there was one job that I worked
at in the retail industry where we had
uh a male manager and then all of the
other employees were attractive women
all of them and it was and very obvious
and everybody knew it all the other
retail stores around us you know they
knew that the old of the girls that
worked there were particularly good
looking and that there would always be
like a new flow of good looking women
um but overall I think when you're uh a
Confident Woman then you can work with
other confident women and when you are a
Confident Woman you can take leadership
from a man
okay what about you
I would say for me personally the
differences between competence and
incompetence so if you're a competent
leader you're competent and then the
differentiating factor between a man and
a woman is if you're disappointed by a
rubbish woman boss is because they've
been unkind to you or been overly
critical or been overly judgmental and
then if you have a mailbox that's
incompetent it's because he made a pass
at you or he made you feel smaller than
you should have felt or he belittled you
in front of people when actually he was
the one that was wrong so I think the
differentiation comes between their
levels of incompetence but competence is
competence irrespective of your male or
female
okay what do you think I think it's 50
50. I think I've had good and bad like
with a male manager that I had he was
all about looks and then
my previous manager who's a female
she was just very laid back so yeah I
think it's 50 50.
was you asking the girls or just like oh
um yeah we'll do girls first go ahead
um I I agree with like what you were
saying about competence so if you have
experience if you care about the work
that you do
um whether you're male or female you
will like brush up on your leadership
skills
um women lead the home so I mean I'm a
bit old school so I believe that like
technically
push comes to shove a man should leave
the lead the home
but in terms of the running of the home
the organization the family
the you know like multitasking
everything else how things look
um
organizing the finances thinking about
Investments like women lead
um and I've had an amazing female leader
and I've had a shh am I allowed to swear
yeah you can swear I've had like a
really [ __ ] female boss who was a [ __ ]
like yeah she was horrible
um and I was really young and yeah she
yeah but I've so I've had both
um but I'm men I've like and I've had
it's same I've had really good men
bosses
um
or like colleagues and then but men in
leadership
I trust women more like competent women
like there's a something really special
when like strong women come together and
work together it's like Sisterhood and
it's rare like I say I don't
sorority houses versus frat houses the
Frat houses they're like best friends
for life you're right like you're right
men as groups like Bond better like
their Bros more like they are like they
play sports together so they do more
things as a group
um but when you like get a good mix like
I don't know how to explain it I think
that's to do with the competency like if
you are a healthy person and you find
another healthy person there will be
healthy things happening
um so you know you're getting old but if
you're dealing with your trauma with
getting old and like the way that that
makes you feel and you're faced with a
beautiful young woman you are not going
to take out those feelings on her I
don't know it exists there are nice
people out there but it's rare I think
it's common though I think older women
bully younger women a lot
I hear you it's like like mother via
like a mother-daughter relationship well
it's almost like it's only I I've
noticed it's usually I'm not saying all
but it's only if they're still single
like if they're married they're like
happily married they got a man but it's
like when they're competing with you
yeah that's that's what I found I hear
you I hear you and the that's the
dynamic between like older women and
younger women but there's also a dynamic
between older men and men in general and
women and if men see you as a sexual
object rather than a work colleague it
happens like I've been a teenager like
groped at work by my boss like did you
report it I didn't report it like I when
these things happen grapes okay no not
grapes but like when like you don't know
how to like especially being a teenager
like I'm going to college really I live
alone and you know I'm going through
things in my life and I've been through
things in my life and it it you
internalize it if that makes sense like
you feel like you've done something
wrong with your toes like I'm feisty so
like I put it on him and I like showed
him it's not that bad but like what do
you mean you put it I put it on him like
bro like it's not that kind of party
like I'm from South London
no like I didn't like straddle him in
the cafe but like I just showed him like
that's not cool but
yeah like when there's such a difference
between age and like experience and just
in general like even if there's not that
difference between Asian experience like
men think that they can
be inappropriate and that's okay you
know some men some men most men because
if you know you can't say most you
because you've got to look at a woman's
experience and you've got to look at
they do research like if I've spoken to
100 men in my life and 89.9 you think
have moved in this type of way
ninety percent of men 89.9 okay you
think 89.9 have moved mad
no that's not my experience like I just
wouldn't I mean when I was when I was
young I had a coach hit on me but I
wouldn't generalize all men with that
89.9 yeah no not even close I would say
like I would say most men are good men
you know what you're saying do you have
any brothers
I have two brothers one which is AWOL
and the other which is dirty but kind of
good so so if you put your brothers in
the room with us that's foreman and then
you put wait Colby said that's five you
put a blessing here that's six um and
Mary just left that was seven if you put
another three you're gonna say out of
those Ten Men eight of us are
inappropriately you're you're picking
like my brothers no I'm picking no I'm
picking up I mean you're assuming that
my brother's like are cool no I'm just
picking I'm just picking 10 men and you
said 89.9 so let's say nuts so let's say
out of 10 men yeah nine of them yeah are
men that commit essay and don't know how
to treat women is that what you're
saying so I'm not saying that they
commit sa I never said they would commit
to say I'm saying inappropriate so okay
so okay it's the same way that he said
that older women may like try and put
that on a woman and bring out like their
issues that they have about getting
older and a young woman being
threatening to them
that's one dynamic between an old woman
and a younger woman an older or a
similar age man and a woman from my
experience so I'm not saying in life in
general this is for everybody but from
my experience
over 50 closer towards 89. okay it has
been inappropriate can you define can
you define an appropriate so
like passes like like what's passes so
you just mean like you look like mad
looking at your blouse like all like do
you know what I mean like like I can
give a good example why yes please thank
you because I was at work sorry I could
give a good example I forgot my back was
so far away
um I was at work um one day and I was
like going through my shift my job is
one of those jobs where you get there I
don't really wear my uniform to work
because I don't like to commute in my
uniform so I'll change when I get there
whether or not so I've gone on the shop
floor and I'm just getting on with my
job I've got probably 11 hour shift just
going through it going through going
through it and one of the like new kind
of old ish like you know when someone
does a job and they come back we had
like someone that had come back to the
shop and they was like on the past
Wherever not doing their job and I'm
just like you know on the shop floor
getting on with everything I'm seeing
them gesture at me like kind of like
glaring towards me and I'm thinking who
who is it um this is a lack safe and
it's a runner like I work in Hospitality
so okay so like say for some like head
waitress that's my position senior
waitress on the shop floor and I'm just
doing my day-to-day like you know
residents and um they was doing their
job but it's like they was glaring at me
at a point I was thinking um how can I
help but I'm kind of like not saying
nothing I'm kind of looking at them like
and it's it's two guys no it's one guy
this one one guy this is just somebody
that's not necessarily on a higher
hierarchy and establishment but it
doesn't make a difference like men male
whatever so um yeah he's glaring at me
and I'm looking back like how can I help
and he's kind of like looked down
because obviously being a female you'll
be conscious of when I'm when a mouse
looking at you this is what I thought
and Stephanie's trying to explain like
you know when someone's kind of giving
you kind of like not uncomfortableness
but I'm not sure what you're trying to
say but you're not saying nothing so
you're leaving it out in the open so
I've had to try and interpretate what
he's looking at so I've looked down and
my flies are undone when was you gonna
say something because you've been
looking at my front for a very long time
maybe you've been looking at my crotch
and when I made like the you know the
announcement of like oh like was you not
gonna say anything he was like I liked
it like what what does that mean he was
hitting on you but that's the point like
why why why is that something that you
know it's weird it's just weird and guys
tend to do things like in their mind
people seems light-hearted but it's very
serious yeah
not really I flirted with the guy at
work I was doing like a six hour shift
with my flies undone yeah but the thing
is he didn't say anything so the thing
is you have to be clear you have to be
very very clear in what you're saying so
you explaining for her but you can't
explain for her per situation so you'll
give him in yours right but what I take
from this yeah what I take from this as
a man's been inappropriate that's what
you're talking about but when you start
talking about
an 89.g do you know what you're saying
you're saying when you walk down the
street 90 of men are gonna do a Madness
are gonna treat you inappropriately so
then you can't then retract that to 50
that could be more likely 50 you know a
guy could maybe be like this or not be
like that as a man when we listen to
women talk like this we have to listen
to what you're saying and unless a man
has actually done something that you can
concretely say he did this I reported
this what we hear is just what we always
hear from women depending on what you
feel is how you feel the scenario was
but if you didn't report it if it wasn't
recorded all we have to go on is just
what you believe it is and you can't
even be clearing what you believe it is
what happened my response agree with
that like sorry but I disagree with that
because you're saying that unless
someone reports it you only have their
like version of events to go on yeah but
there are people yeah yeah yeah sorry
guys but there are people who do report
things and it's still their version of
events but you didn't report it though
when people report grape issues or sa
issues it's still he say she say because
if you're in a relationship with someone
if it's your uncle yeah whoever it is
it's a personal thing you understand
when you like people aren't here right
now there's a whole heap of people in
this room yeah but when your man
does certain things your man you know
and you haven't agreed to it it's still
a he say she say did you report it no no
I'm saying to you but did you reply I'm
saying to you that whether it's reported
but did you report it to hear what I
have to say I'm saying to you that
whether it's reported or whether it's
not reported it's silly he say she said
and the reason why people don't report
it is because it's silly he say she say
there's no evidence
in my room it doesn't work right there's
no camera in my room to prove that what
I'm saying so why do you report it who
but what are you talking about not
talking about hypothetical okay okay so
do you understand the cost yes I do I do
I do I do
okay wait wait wait wait wait but even
even when it's a he said she said people
have patterns of behavior like honestly
I think it's selfish not to report it I
genuinely think it's selfish like you
want him to do that to someone else if
it genuinely happened like why would you
not report it because even if even if
like let's say justice isn't served for
you if 10 girls come forward with the
same story eventually they can build a
case against a guy it's happened I've
seen it happen so it's genuinely selfish
if you don't so when you say he say
shishi every time you go to the police
and you make an accusation against
someone a report it's always he says you
say nothing is ever concrete the reason
why you go to the police is so that a
case can be pulled against a person so
if I have five girls that say to me my
boss was inappropriate to me and I said
to you okay cool well my sister says to
me my boss wasn't appropriate to I said
the first thing you do is go and report
it if five women do not report it then
they say to me oh it's because of he say
shishay whose fault is that but we're
not even blaming people I'm not blaming
because you said to me because you are
no no no no no no no
wait guys guys guys guys listen for a
second here she said said to me
apparently I don't understand that he's
but I'm saying I do understand if
someone does something to you this is
look let me look to the camera ladies
women if somebody does something to you
in your workplace in your home any man
is inappropriate you need to go and
report it straight away you need to and
this is what I'm advocate for because if
you come on a platform and you say oh my
man this this did this to me my boy my
boss did it to me and you tell me and I
said so what did you do about you said
nothing I'm sorry I could just cut I
just can't I just can't take everyone
that says that the truth I'm sorry I
can't do that but can we just I think
that's quickly which really really
should add that some women
are so traumatized thank you by what
they have experienced thank you they
find it difficult have you experienced
essay pearly things or you have you
which is which I mean the definition the
definition for essay is so broad now
what is the definition I don't even know
they change it every year but arguably I
could yeah I could argue that I have and
did you report every experience of essay
yes every single experience it doesn't
happen to me that many times
hey you are so brave then for Having the
courage to do it but some women's it's
what if the person you're supposed to no
and I'm saying and and it's arguably
because it's like nowadays you can
report someone grabbing your butt at a
bar
but if that's not warranted or that's
not environment but some people don't
think that's like a higher enough
doesn't matter
that's what I say it's so broad but I'm
saying like like if you're to me okay it
doesn't make sense to me if you can come
on a podcast and talk about something
but you can't talk about it to the
police exactly so I understand that some
people like okay they might they might
not want to talk about it publicly or
they might like if they're afraid then
they wouldn't go to my podcast and they
wouldn't go to the police either but so
like again but I still think it's
selfish I think I think if you if you
you're telling me I'm selfish for being
a 17 year old girl who lives in a hostel
you don't know what I've experienced
previous to that for not reporting my
boss who's probably about 40 years old
and excuse me let me land don't
interrupt me I'm just saying yes I'm not
asking you I was asking pearly things
right yes I'm asking you if you think
I'm selfish I'm a child at this point
yeah I've been sexually
all of them things that you know you can
say
um by yeah like by all you can't you
can't tell me nothing how whatever your
opinion is that's your business yeah
because I know my situation yeah and
what I have walked through in the in
that situation right now I'm 33 years
old yeah so it's different now of course
I can sit down I work with I do I work
in the community but at that age yeah
that young age I am a child I can't even
open a bank account on my own yeah and
you're telling me I am selfish
well whatever you can't do you can do a
lot easier
you're trying to make jokes and you're
trying to interject
diverse
okay okay have you gone through okay
okay no no no no okay you asked me the
question first yeah and then you want it
this rant I did so I want to run you
know
okay do I think that's selfish yes yeah
I think because then other girls have to
deal with it
like I just think if if something
happened to me that was so traumatizing
like I wouldn't want other girls to go
through that you like basically I can't
I can't judge other people you can say
what you want and feel what you want
yeah and have your opinion and that
doesn't mean that much to me because you
don't know what people go through what
your capacity is at 17 I don't know if
you went through your experiences at
that age and if you was living in a
hostel at that age and if you had gone
through what I had gone through at that
age yeah we're different people Jonathan
I'm saying to you yeah are you sure I
know we're different people we're
different people so that's what I'm
saying you might have the capacity you
might have the support you might be
living at home you might have your mum
to rub your back at the police station I
wasn't in that situation so there are
many people that are experiencing things
and I haven't got no judgment for you do
what you can do because why is it up to
the victims to find and licked out you
know as a child to to to to to build up
a case against these people when you
have the capacity yes
I encourage I support but find an
organization if you don't think you can
do it on your own if you are unsure get
the support that you need the main thing
is that you have got support to get
through the trauma of Very Yes you get
your brand grabbed at a nightclub but
there's varying different traumas
there's an organization it's called the
police so listen to this I'll just
listened to you no no sorry can I talk
because I just listen to you I've
listened to scars okay
so what you're doing now let you speak
with let you tell your story let you
tell your passion but I'm sorry but the
world doesn't owe any one of us
understanding lots of people are going
through lots of things end of the day
it's very selfish for you to be
assaulted by a man or whatever you said
and he's 40 years harassed or whatever
it is but it's it's made you feel this
strongly about it it's gone into your
life and it's obviously followed you you
have let let this man go into the world
and possibly do it to many other women
before this is like knowing a man is
actually like um for example if someone
touch kids and you knew they did that
and you never wanted no you wasn't your
17
technically okay so if you're going to
keep doing this then we're not going to
able to get off because basically you
setting my 17 you can open a bank
account you can open a bank account at
11 years old what tends to happen is a
lot of people come over here and they're
trying to act like oh when I wasn't I
wasn't an adult 17 you knew right from
wrong end of the day if you had any
family any people around you if you
didn't call you to scenario understand
that but you have the police there you
cannot come into a platform and be this
fluid and but it's articulate and
challenged Paul and say to myself oh you
know what I couldn't go to the police
there's nobody around the police is
there then you say to me okay I got
attacked by the police okay so you don't
have or whatever it is okay cool why am
I gonna go to the police okay okay so
now I've got 15 have assaulted Me Okay
cool so now we can't go to the police
right so you know who do we go to well
I'm just discovering who do we report it
to you I'm just discovering my manager
who do we report you're telling me you
can't go to the police most people can
go to the police but you're saying to me
so I don't have to take this on board do
you have
um to see the scars see what you're
doing is yeah because he said you
because the moment I do you don't have
nothing to push back on you just really
so what big man talk talk let me hear
what you want to say can I present
something a second one second okay okay
let him finish because the thing is yeah
we're not going to be able to have a
conversation if you keep doing this
because you keep getting triggered why
are you getting so triggered like that's
like that no if this is trauma let's not
talk about it because you're getting
very triggered by it and you don't have
to speak about it if this is causing you
trauma because we can't even have a
conversation in order for me to have a
conversation we're gonna ask you some
questions we're gonna have to diverge
and every time I do you get triggered
interrupt me so I I don't want to do it
if we can't do it Paul there's no point
say what you have to say he said you're
gonna land is that is that what you had
to say is that what you have to say
let's take it take it okay that's what I
thought all right let me let me present
something to you Steph yeah yes for the
rest of us to just listen
two so Steph let's say you could you
were looking right now at 17 year old
girl who has just experienced your
flower in the wall you see a 17 year old
girl who's just experienced what you
went through
um with the police with that with those
situations
what right now sitting here now what do
you think are the steps that that 17
year old girl should take I'd like to
hear from the rest of the panel I've
heard I've heard from two men okay
I'm asking
I'm asking you directly
my advice and my concern is for her
mental health and that she is supported
so I my priority over speaking to the
police which I think is the best course
of action if she feels able to do so is
to make sure that somebody she trusts
whether it's a member of her family
whether it's a friend whoever is aware
of her situation because if she's
feeling low if you know I mean what
that's my concern you're not my general
concern I don't think the number one
concern would be to stop it from
happening again
because because it happened to her so
now it could happen to 10 girls or it
could happen to one girl I think it's a
point of view situation
yeah from trauma and someone coming from
stoicism so it's two completely
different point of views that don't
interject so I get what you're saying in
the sense that say it with your chest
right
those things happen to you they were
awful I'm very sorry but your statistic
is you're coming at home with maths your
math is off right and she's saying these
things happen to me so obviously there's
going to be a a complete non so can I
just stop it I'll let you go on it you
know what it is I've come on this
platform before I have three sisters I
have four nieces like I am very much
I've just been spending the whole day
with my niece you can look at my story
playing with them yeah I have a very
good relationship with my younger sister
and we speak about a lot of things so
if you said you never if you don't have
people around you and you can't go to
the police then I'm all concerned that
there's men around here and doing things
to women because I keep hearing this and
this is not how I was raised so I'm like
what can we do to stop this and whenever
but whenever I try to speak about what
can we do to stop this or what can we do
to at least bring awareness to us it
just goes round and round around a
suggestion of what people can do to stop
this is perhaps okay right something's
awful has happened to you you don't feel
like you can say it right you don't feel
like you have that safe space to say it
so you hold on to it it becomes an
internal trauma and then when someone
mentioned it to you you fly off the
handle that's how most people handle
these situations but what you're saying
is what can I do so when someone flies
off the handle yeah don't come up with
them with maths come at them from I
understand
that you are this reaction comes from a
place of fear and anger you're asking
them to communicate like a woman not a
man no no no in fact I'm asking him to
just communicate with me no you're
asking him to communicate well then
you're putting different versions let me
let me sorry sorry one second again we
come to the dichotomy as well yeah one
second this I think this is interesting
so go back to matching us and like you
know dominance of men over
paranormalities
you know in a very subtle manner you
can't divert your vocabulary Alex Alex
you're gonna jump in after me but hold
on a second what you're doing is what
see okay so you're doing tone police and
we get this every single week no because
you've literally just done what the girl
did the last week and the girl did the
last week if you go look on my story on
Tick Tock it's going viral every single
time a man speaks I have a woman every
time a man makes a point it's every time
a man makes a point now it's your tone I
was even trying to no no but what I'm
talking about Alex let me just say and
you can just literally come after me
pull you go but the reason I want to
speak about this because men we speak
direct we are not women okay so we have
a different vocal tone we have a
different bass on it right when a man
articulates himself or men are direct
what women tend to do we go around the
houses we've just spent a lot of time
going around to get to the bottom of
something I completely understand what
you're saying but when you speak about
men's tone we are not women and you
don't want us to be women that's the
point that I was making I thought that
you over you didn't understand what I
was trying to say Powell was saying that
she was mating trying to make you speak
as if he was a female yeah you can't do
okay cool cool that's part of it yeah
the reason of this whole topic which is
men harassment within the workplace and
what we were saying about how men can
come across towards women when we are
innocent do you think Alex will just
take this for me you can't die what's
the word like you can't what's you can't
like be a woman adapt that's what I'm
looking for being sensitive to her no
it's adapter like adaptation you can't
adapt you're not even choosing to be on
a level to be like you know let me try
and work out know what I need to be a
female because physically you can't be
yeah we understand that but there's a
part of your brain that can click
no no because basically what you want me
to do is you want me to basically tiptoe
around this whole thing no because
basically all I've done is simply ask
her a question I've listened to what
you've said I've asked you why don't you
report it you told me you couldn't go to
the police you told me you got scars
you've told me all the different things
here cool but if there's my concern is
is that when this happens women don't
and it's men that's walking around and
it's continuing to happen to so when I
say what can we do yeah because with a
girl in your situation now and she
hasn't got Brothers she hasn't got a
family she's in a hostel as well yeah
what does she do she can't go to the
police
what you can do someone just gave you an
example is that as a man what you could
do for a woman or a young girl in that
situation someone else is giving you an
example of what you can do I was asked
what I'd advise other young people in
this situation to do so if you you asked
in a question feel free to listen to
some options you don't have to take them
on as I think these are valid examples
there's even an advert on TV that states
exactly this way it's like a guys I'm in
the park of his friends whether or not a
woman wants Class A guy turns around
starts rubbernecking oh yeah right
rubbernecking is like a saying of like
when a guy you know breaks his neck to
like put Jesse's at a woman or just
throw things out he just throws it throw
things up verbally like messages like
maybe you can say oh he cat calls yeah
there's so many different um
terminologies but Robin is a terminology
obviously
what is the cat calling have to do with
them calling is more a vocalization
whereas yeah rubber necking is the
Turning of the neck yeah but it was both
like when they're like damn yes yeah
that's what I'm trying to say yeah the
way it is that bad I'm trying to land
not necessarily that's a bad or a good
thing but the point I'm trying to make
is the advert was stating sexual
harassment and they were saying that
basically within that situation let me
land quickly
um the guy turns around and his friend
basically was like to him like don't do
that like he stepped in and allowed him
to like understand that maybe that woman
might feel it's inappropriate maybe to
his mind he's just like oh what's your
number you look nice well them jeans are
tight or whatever do you feel nice
to me personally I've got a bit of a
stronger exterior and interior so those
things don't really phase me depending
on how I'm approached so for myself no
but for another woman that's a bit more
fragile than me do you think that's
confusing for a man it can be yeah
like even with the workplace like the
number one before
um dating apps the number one people
place that people would meet was work so
it's kind of confusing because sometimes
um girls are into it when their bosses
hit on them this is a thing and like and
other times like girls actively seek out
their bosses and try to sleep with them
we had a different read the room yeah
what do you mean like for example if
there's a female who's interested in her
boss that's different to a female who
the male manager needs to read the room
that that causes everything do you think
girls ever do you think girls ever give
mixed signals or flirt for attention
definitely do I don't know who said we
definitely definitely so do you think
that's confusing for men and sometimes
yes I feel like women have sexual sex
appeal like we have sexual attractions
that we can you know sometimes put out
consciously or unconsciously to milk out
to counterparts and they can taken upon
themselves to decide whether it's
deliberate or you know she just
accidentally walked past me and her bum
was shaking was she shaking that by me
she was walking past me right but I'm
like I'm saying like one girl you know
he might turn and say damn and one girl
might think that's disgusting and be
traumatized and one girl might be like
okay you know and so you don't think
that's confusing for me it can be but I
feel like that's where you then break
the ice with vocalization you start
vocalizing like rather do you do you you
know do you feel comfortable with what
I'm saying or you know you try to break
the eye some guys don't tend to go into
it they just keep at that level of you
know snappiness like they're trying to
be Charming or witty or whatever it is
where other guys have a bit more context
to them they will be like you know I
would like to speak to you or you know I
thought that comment would be you know
something I'll get your attention oh
this is why I don't move to girls I said
it before I say it to Cameron no I don't
move the girls I haven't moved I haven't
I haven't moved um
I'll tell you girls move to me how did
you
how do you feel about that do you feel
like you're being sexually harassed or
maybe put upon oh okay let me let me buy
it no see this is wondering so when you
so when a man moves you how does he grab
your phone and some guys have done
differently
that might be in his mind I mean that
might not be his level of okay okay I
think I think if you don't know how to
approach someone if you have to if you
if I move up to go I don't know I grab a
thigh what do you think's gonna happen
to me we're just speaking about this so
that's just let's just take that away if
you allowed Paul just said a girl might
accept that and another girl might not
no but no man should be true no man okay
guys let me put in the camera so when
you say guys dude some guys the guys you
deal with I would never never dealt with
a guy that's ever done that okay so then
so then who are we talking about I'm
giving experiences and obviously I've
been doing this this lifetime a while to
have experience it and see things you
know not necessarily every experience is
my personal experience yeah it might be
a bad curious experience through someone
else's life you know but I think okay so
when we're talking about experience
let's try and keep to what
no because when I say okay for example
when we say women we say more than women
because we're not speaking about all
women and when we speak Modern Men a lot
of modern men are very forward
especially with the lifestyle and living
that has been accommodated these days
they're very forward of their their
personas should I say the way they want
to move and I feel like they have to
uphold a certain level of interaction to
make it make sense in their minds not
necessarily that needs to make sense in
the actual physicality in their minds it
looks good okay so let me get back to
you when I was talking about I'm not
moving to girls so especially with the
whole me too movement you know what's
happening now is yeah like this is all
I've always been this way before um but
I'm going to say to men the reason why
so we don't know what for for one woman
it's okay to you know pull up on and say
do the whole Chris Brown thing excuse me
you know yeah the whole 90s r b like put
up on the car but it might be cute for
you for another woman it might be a red
flag it might be it might trigger trauma
right so it's it's pretty safe for me to
say that if you want a man to come up to
you and this is what women should do
with old you will let a man know there's
a lot of ways that a woman can let a man
know that she wants him to come up to
her she can you know you I'm listen we
have all these women here I'm sure if
you want to let a man know to approach
you you know how to do it women have
been doing this forever right you can
look at a man you can smile at a man you
can wink he could even walk past him and
drop something and make him pick it up
or make him come to get it and then you
can do that right women know how to make
a man not approach it that's the
difference between a random girl walking
past me me trying to grab up her arm and
say excuse she's like who she's going
about her business [ __ ] it's called yes
and no what do you mean it's a simple
yes and no what do you mean what do you
mean what do I mean you're saying that a
woman lets you know whether she's
injured yes yo come no I'm not
interested it's a simple yes or no no no
so so as a woman yeah as a woman I don't
even have to get to that point I don't
have to approach you you can literally
look at me and if you if you look at me
in a way I give you a look right now
that makes you feel like I like you
what's happening I'll I'll approach you
speak
what I said what's your approach I've
linked at you I don't know
yeah okay okay so um what about you
um with oh wait no you were next you
were next right
um did you go because we're talking
about yeah okay what is your overall
experience with female leadership
compared with male leadership in your
industry
um I'll be brief wow
I've had both I enjoy men I personally
respect men's decision making it's
quicker it's less layers it's less fuss
I don't care if you can't do something
because you're on your period let's move
thank you it's extremely exhausting when
especially in a business place we need
to make decisions quick and they need to
be Innovative so with women I'm not
saying they're not these things but it
takes them longer to make that decision
to be Innovative it takes them longer to
make a decision the decision is keeps
changing I'm not saying men don't have
that capacity but that capacity seems to
be shorter which is what I enjoy more
um I've experienced
you feel that way about yourself
what do you mean what you just said
about women leaders yeah I wouldn't yep
I wouldn't want to
I would be my own boss if I had to say
much if I had to
um lead I would prefer a male boss
that's just me
like I'm just like I do what I do you do
what you do I agree with you I just
think they're better at it yeah
my feminine power to be I feel like they
need me and I need them
um I don't even just because his title
is more I'm like I'm the underdog he
can't do that without me okay this man
needs me okay
men need women I'm so confident men
needing women no I'm chilling women I'm
chilled like cool if you need to have
have the title darling I don't mind is
money coming in love it um I've had
inappropriate on both ends male and
female
um the female inappropriateness was the
bullying the patronizing the being weird
with other people and the gossiping
that's what I didn't like there was a
lack of Integrity like why are you
spreading these beautiful girls isn't
that mad 80 of bullying is from women I
believe it yeah when I heard the
statistics it made sense too yeah that's
over 60 000 or like 60 000 people took
that I believe that I genuinely believe
that they just be weird
um but inappropriate with the men uh
it's been flirting or sometimes it's
just the inappropriateness for me is
you're really chilling like scratching
your balls at the top because you're
like I'm the Man sort of thing and
that's I feel like that's enough what do
you mean chilling scratching the people
at the top work like 89 like my dad is
one of those CEOs he worked 80 hours a
week my whole life and respect to your
dad but that's your dad some people get
to the top and start chilling and they
just like I'm not saying your job isn't
to chill because you've worked your way
it should be smarter not harder at that
point but I mean scratching their balls
is like taking away to relaxed approach
do you do you know these men in like the
one one percent two percent three
percent what do you mean like do you
know them personally
um yeah I've worked for just like two
but the inappropriateness was like one
was really relaxed and just taking drugs
like yeah you were going in
in the bus and he's at the top where I
find women to be not more scared but
they will think in way more layers than
to do that then it's just like I'm
risking it for the biscuit yeah men are
more risky I agree with you even when
you think about fmcg and you go above on
a few levels and okay there are less
women there and they are what wait say
that again sorry I don't know what FM
sorry is that a British this is a
British thing is it is it like a
business type yeah sorry fast it's an
acronym I'm sorry I should put like five
pound in the jar to tell everyone I am
the worst person I do at work as well
and I now I've done it just in front of
many people
um fast-moving consumer goods so you
have to be able to make decisions
quickly you have to be Innovative I work
in that role right now I just feel like
women are getting a really bad bum deal
out of this the harder we work the
higher we go we're still decks because
we have to behave in the same way but
not the same way like I'm doing it I'm
living it like I really think it's not
that deep guys like it doesn't matter
what you have just get on with it jfdi
just [ __ ] do it like let's go I I I I
what do you mean like I just find that
this whole dichotomy between men and
women and like it just if it's that if
they're a bad boss they're a bad boss it
doesn't matter well I think it's what's
interesting is that women men most men
say they don't have a preference it was
like 50 50. where women say they don't
like working for women yeah so it's I
don't know and maybe I have a difficulty
with personal experience but I've had a
bad woman boss and I've had a bad man
boss but I've had lots of bosses and
I've been a boss and my personal
experience is that if you're a dick
you're a dick it doesn't matter what
genitalia you have you're gonna be a
dick okay what do you think well yeah I
agree realistically on that point
um I have very limited personal
experience but um
I've had yeah both like realistically my
experience the female like on-site
manager was horrible like personal like
going to personal topics
um but that was on the situation to be
honest I think it's just depended on the
person realistically because there are
different experiences from everybody
here about a male manager being an
appropriate female manager being
inappropriate I know with generalizing
but
I just think yeah it's dependent on the
person realistically my experience
um
my
manager was a male
um he was fine but he was in a
relationship it's very different like
you know
scenes but uh on-site female manager
wasn't great but it was personal you
know she was older than me she was
jealous in a way of different
experiences but
I do think if it was a different
um
experience with the
girl yeah well it's yeah it's like it
was yeah the experience was very um
awkward between me and her it became
personal without me wanting it to be at
all but um yeah so some people just some
people just like that they don't care
sometimes they just go for it hey um I
need you guys to start with the side
talking
um because we can hear it in the mics go
ahead yeah but realistically my
experience is more and obviously my
female manager wasn't as good as the
male however I don't think that can
speak for everybody and a general
experience of is male management better
than female you know what I mean
okay
um what up what about you
I mean I don't have much experience but
like from what I've experienced I
definitely prefer like male leadership
for sure because I feel sorry I feel
like it's more of a relaxed environment
like with women it's always or this this
and this this and that it's like I don't
have time for it we're all here for
10.50 an hour like we're not like you
know much different so like like I said
I don't have much experience but I
definitely prefer male leadership it's
more laid back we can get on with our
jobs and that's that do you know what I
mean
do you guys think it's um offensive to
make General statements about a gender
no example men tend to be better in
leadership I mean stereotypes are there
for a reason and they come from
somewhere you know but overall we are
generalizing and I feel like there's a
lot of like we've been bashing right now
within the workplace but if we look at
it as well you know
in history the women went to work what
sort of from the 50s and 60s and whereas
we first had you know the women being
the hormone
Homemaker that's the word I'm looking
for work on like the farm too yeah yeah
I'm sorry I'm thinking you awesome
actually I was thinking about the us too
that's where I read the statistics from
but basically when the women went into
the workforce sort of the family side of
things struggled that was also when
divorce rates went up by I think like 80
or something crazy like that but it was
also after the development of birth
control yes it all came around the same
same time yeah but I mean um they're
like bring me back to the streets
I think we're gonna be that
particular like men are better than
leaders oh where is this world going I
can't say nothing I can't just think out
loud at this point bloody hell no wait
so you're saying we should be able to
say that
it's just European yeah it's not exactly
feeling anybody hasn't got any
references into anything graphic or
inappropriate
yeah because I just don't know what
keeps saying we keep saying there are
exceptions and I'm like I know there are
exceptions but like we can make General
statements about it to be there though I
do think it depends on the topic with
generalization like the topics that we
had before that were very like it could
be very yeah touch like touchy in
subjects it generalizing can be too much
like when you were both going talking
about like the specifics of the numbers
you were using it can be dependent on
the topic really say generalization we
all do it with everything but yeah we've
certain like subjects you have to be a
bit more particular I think I think
nowadays
um
with the rise
and evolution of feminism
um more women
who hear
um certain generalizations that don't
necessarily paint
um women in a good light will take
umbrage to those generalizations and
then those will be that they will be the
ones to say something you know get
triggered and want to kind of dispute it
or even if even if it's a factual thing
they will still say I don't agree you
can still fudge the numbers though so
statistically there are more men in the
workforce therefore the statistics will
lean better into their that favor so in
order to say that men are better leaders
numerically they are better leaders
because they asked women the the study I
was saying was um they they picked
female lead Industries and they're like
with the female-led industry I can I can
I can read it you have to be very
careful pearly things about statistics
guys watch it guys Who's laughing in the
mic it's me I'm sorry I'm sorry I
apologize what should we go off our
feelings so if we don't go off of stats
what are we going to go off of but I can
like who wrote These statistics who
funded these statistics thank you the
let's see
a new study UCLA okay it's a university
yeah I know the I know the University
thank you yeah it says I've taught at
UCLA
[Music]
um
a much smaller survey by UCLA Law Firm
staff UCLA yeah them it's a college
American so it's not UCL no they they
took stats from the UK to I think no no
this is American oh it's American yeah I
think interesting I think what she's
trying to say thank you um is just how
many people
would actually fill out stuff to do with
this and then those demographic of
people I'm not I don't care for what I'm
actually saying just trying to reference
what she's saying so those people that
would fill out a survey versus people
that wouldn't feel like surfing
this is just it's just I just feel like
sometimes we jump through hoops whenever
women like I just feel like sometimes I
feel like we we jump through hoops
whenever women look bad like to to
somehow change the narrative for us not
to look bad but we can say women run the
world and nobody nobody even pushes back
on that okay so it's like you have to
understand we can always so
with Statistics okay so men line numbers
don't men like women like numbers don't
lie but numbers can be manipulated
depending on who's looking at them and
what they wanted to say so we can say
that right but if we look generally how
the world since the beginning of time
has done censuses then we we we take the
majority or we take it we take a slice
of it and then we we generalize right if
we don't do that we will never ever able
to come to some type of like general you
know decision on something so we have to
do that it might not be perfect
Sometimes some people might get roped
into it some people might get left out
but this is the best that we have and
this is what and this is what the world
has been using since the beginning of
time from when from when Pontius Pilate
had to go do sentences and go literally
from then them times there from when the
Passover was happening and they wanted
to know how many people were inside each
from them times they'd be taking numbers
down yeah so unless one of you guys can
give me I was gonna say I can give me
one day because because you're speaking
about before the dawn of time before the
dawn of time it was a man's man's world
that's the saying that a lot of people
like to bring up here from back in the
day like it's a man's world everything's
very man-made because men built the
world yeah but for me it's like
condition of the Mind see it from my
perspective I did psychology so I
believe that everything is like some
form of like introductory it's like
planting a seed it's going to grow if
I'm always surrounded by male
counterparts in power if I'm always
being told that a male is the one that's
meant to hold me down you know protect
me like Amel is meant to be you know my
version of God essentially because he's
meant to be my everything at this point
this is the society that they built up
on we've created the women couldn't do
it yeah there's no such thing that we
couldn't we wasn't given a child no we
were that we could have done it just
like the men did it but like no but wait
wait but no but no Society wait wait
wait wait stop do not interrupt me no no
society that has stood the test of time
was run by women women had just as much
opportunity as men
and men and men still run the world I
mean they run our whole infrastructure
if if men disappeared tomorrow like the
lights would go out the plumbing would
stop women disappeared they would be
fine but it's possible to to an extent
but the point that I'm trying to makers
that imagine if you're only being
surrounded by a male energy you're not
going to know any difference to them
yeah but I want to know I want to know
I've had it statistics I'm giving more
prominent Mal do you get it because
everyone's been surrounded by my mouth
if he was forced to being a female you
know I am we live okay so management
wise we're talking about management no
but I'm talking about consent I'm
talking about census and getting a
demographic of people I want to know how
the fact that men like men are there
like what you say make sixty thousand
women all the senses say that actually
working for a woman creates me more
problems I want to know what what has
men done to make women say actually if I
work for a woman I don't actually like
it as much momentum sixty thousand sixty
thousand men are attracted to women so
of course women are going to have a
better working experience working for
men
women are attracted to men
yeah it's equal it's equal but the only
difference is that women women don't
like working for women they like working
for men men say I don't care you know I
feel like men have a certain approach
like we're saying women and men are very
different in the workplace and I feel
like their approaches are different so
maybe males tend to like interactive
women in a more like you know they
understand the nature of women hiring
people has actually like kind of put me
like understand like why there's more
men and Leadership positions and
positions of power because I found like
the the best paid jobs and the high like
jobs like women don't want to do because
it's they're stressful so like
so I'll give you an example so my
recruiting my recruiter like that's
probably one of the highest paid jobs I
have that's a really hard job to get
that many people in like what any 20 to
50 girls four days a week that's really
hard and stressful because if you don't
get me guests like the whole show fails
so it's it's paid well but it's also
high stress but I I had um my roommate
just I said you would make way more
money you can do this job she did it for
a week she said you can't pay me to do
this this sucks and when I when I I
brought the job to my team no one on my
team wanted to do it and it's like they
could make double what they're making at
their jobs that they do but it's hard
oh you showed us I've been I agree but
that may be a little bit of law of
averages yeah what do you mean uh law of
average of like obviously it would have
been a waste of time and money that's
why you wouldn't go on the route of law
on average but if you tried more and
more girls you would have stumbled
across one that could handle it you did
it oh I'm not saying that like no women
can do it no that's not what I'm saying
that I'm like I I would I would kill I
used to do recruiting I would kill oh my
God I would I would kill the recruiting
but like I just think in general women
don't want to do those jobs like like
across the board like women don't want
the super high stress jobs
and even even like oil rigs right like
that that's a six-figure job you can do
right away how many of y'all want to go
work on an oil rig
yeah yeah you couldn't pay me to they
could pay me 300K a year you would not
catch me on an oil rate that goes back
to like it's a man's world a lot of
things were started from men doing a lot
of yeah I'm saying nope
I think imagine I think women just don't
want to do hard jobs I feel like we just
don't want to be something that doesn't
serve us well I feel like for myself I
don't mind doing a job that can be a bit
you know intense but it needs to serve
me well I feel like some women that feel
like they're being served well so 100 so
you could work you could work on the
nights on the trains engineering on
training or guys on the orange and that
yeah yeah you can there's not nothing
stopping you from doing that job nothing
for me you can make 100K doing that job
yeah it doesn't how can 100K not serve
you well not to say that 100K is not
saving me well but do I want to be
bending and straining my back long term
for how many years that's going to give
me a long term you know Health
right right
okay but if we don't do it okay wait so
let me do that no no no no no no but if
we don't do that job if we don't do that
job you cannot catch a train don't
but you
you so so but you
but you won't do something no but this
is this is the video
this is the point when I said like met
like women don't want to build the world
because like even I don't know
in society like you were saying it's
cultural right and like like because
women didn't see like women in positions
of power it's all influence but even
today when we have every opportunity
women still don't want to do it they
don't want to do the hardest jobs which
put your body on the line of course like
I said yeah that's that was one of the
things that I did say even I used to I
wouldn't do it I used to interview there
was there was a point there is a point
where I interviewed um top Executives
um I just decided I wanted more rich
friends and it's kind of funny you can
call them up yeah yeah I just thought it
was like my friend group too broke
and so what I did was I like to network
um this is when I was 22 I just called
them up and said I'm 22. I want to learn
and like I talked to like top Executives
at billion dollar companies and you get
to see the toll like because they've
been working 80 you know on their face
seriously they look so tired they look
so burned out because they've been
working 80 hours a week for 30 40 years
who wants to do that you couldn't pay me
to work that much
just quickly say very I I think it's
also we need to acknowledge that it's
sort of like a generational trauma thing
because if you saw your dad working 80
hours and you're you know that your
granddad did that and then that's the
generation that you came from no trauma
my dad loves it he's still works
maybe not not generational trauma just a
generational pattern should we say but
when you see you know because we lead by
example as parents so we sort of are
conditioned whether it's negatively or
positively to sort of go into the same
sort of roles as our parents it's when
we break those patterns and go off and
do different things that that's like a
little bit strange no no it's just I
make observations and I just I like
again my dad has friends that are in
similar fields in him like do as well as
he does and I'm just saying women I
promise women because the women don't
see it exactly I agree with you on that
yeah because again they've seen their
generations of patterns with maybe
um you know the the home Homemakers
um you know they've seen the Homemakers
or they've seen you know their their the
women in their family in certain roles
and then because they've been you know
again like learning from older these
people we've been we've had been able to
work since the 70s
actually it they say that it takes like
two decades for like a changeably
implemented in society like fully so I
do still think we are changing this
agenda they started entering the
workforce at World War II sorry go ahead
go ahead no no I'm
I just think that it's going to take
more time if women want these big jobs
and they probably won't want the more
physical ones that they're not possible
you know able to do but I think it will
just take longer for women to have those
higher roles maybe so why is it why is
it that when countries where women have
more Choice the pay Gap increases it
doesn't decrease
so if you if you make a list of
countries so like let's say Saudi Arabia
women have less choice and we say in
more what is it either it's eastern
Europe Eastern European no no not
Eastern European it's um there's one
country where it's like but okay let's
take the US there's more free they're
more free right so when you look at
countries that are more free the pay Gap
increases it doesn't decrease and you
get more women like you get more women
being nurses and more men being doctors
rather than decreasing why do you think
that is if if it's like a generational
thing subconsciously for me I have I
don't have kids but I already feel like
that's going to be the hardest job on
Earth
so I'm just like
maybe men do the rest because um
Carrie what
uh do what no my titty uh
um so I'm happy to be on this side of
stuff I'm happy I'm I'm okay I can dip
my toe in over there you know I can
carry a little one
so I can carry on one thing for you I
can help but like
I think subconsciously whether I'm
conditioned or not I just feel like
giving birth and being a mum that is for
life
I'm I don't know but I feel like that's
gonna be harder that's the job I'm yeah
I'm the physical portal
to life the physical and okay guys you
can take over thank you
half of women are in our generation
aren't gonna have kids 50 of women that
are um hit 30 or single and childless
and they're predicting that 40 40 45 of
um women between the ages of 25 and 45
aren't going to have kids why is that
because because feminism's On The Rise
funny things because
um I think women
they can't find a guy they wanna they
can't get a guy that they want to have
kids interesting I think it's I think
it's because I think it's because
feminism's On The Rise I think that's a
part of it I think that the not having
kids and the the title of this uh this
question in fact can modern women be be
men it's all due to the rise of feminism
there are so many reasons though yeah
yeah yeah yeah I think but I think all
of those reasons are connected to the
rise of what would the the other
feminism be that connected to feminism
well apart from feminism why else are
women not having children from 24. they
can't afford it they're predicting
between 25 to 45 and 50 of them what
weight and 50 of women that hit 30 are
single and childless because it's okay
to not want to
yeah except the women over the ages of
45 with no kids or family are the rated
the least happy
they were catching up we're catching up
yeah but can I just say something but
that probably goes down to when you see
older guys getting with younger girls
because is that because they're
miserable it's because they don't want
to date women their age because because
the women their age are miserable I mean
wonderful so sometimes that must be a
fun loving 45 year old so so I I spoke
about this I spoke about this last week
to be fair so
so a lot of women so so you have from 18
to 28 you have let's say 10 years those
are your prime years
um those years when you're going outside
the world moves for you you go into
places you know I'm trying to say to you
get in you get free entry
um the top guys you you know you
literally it's your best time of your
life where everyone sees you between 18
to 20 is when no one really sees Usman
these are when we have to create our
value so women are born with value men
inherently we have to create our value
so a lot of times is you at 18 to 28 you
can pick a guy that's studying you can
pick a guy that's just trying to try
trying to come up it's an ordinary guy
but what you tend to do is you don't
tend to pick these guys you tend to go
for the top 20 of guys that have access
to multiple women so now we have 100 of
women going for 20 of guys and so you
spend 18 to 28 dating Bad Boys dating as
we like to call them Chad and Tyrone and
running up their body so yeah I'm trying
to Tyrone and running up your body count
so then what tends to happen as you get
to 28 is when women start to get a
little bit um oh my God they start to
see the guys they didn't see but now
these guys that you didn't see they
recognize see them and there's a new set
of women so while you're outside now and
you're 28 or 30 there's a whole new set
of women now but you feel as if that the
men in their 30s should be speaking to
you but
um they're not so a lot of the times
what women say is oh men are trying to
find young girls so they can manipulate
them so they can do all these types of
things what they're trying to do is
they're trying to make it fair because
they're not it's now competition but
when we was 18 and 20 and 20 21 23 and
the women were jumping out out of the
big cars in West End all the guys
popping the bottles like we said the
sparklers we had to feel it it was not
nice we had to feel the bit but you
girls didn't care when you was like you
guys literally didn't care so now we're
on our 30s and our life is up and we're
doing really well why would we pick you
when a lot of you girls come with trauma
a lot of you girls come with kids and
awesome and don't have kids and we're
doing really well we'll just look past
you women only swipe right on dating
apps five percent of the time where
men's vibrate 45 percent
yeah so and that's the thing like I
always say women women say things like
men are trash or men are the problems
because they're all sleeping with the
same ones no my okay my point was is are
older men going for younger women
because in their older age are they
miserable so they have to feel they're
getting their confidence back by getting
with younger women no um I think I think
men's lives get better after 45 because
they actually have money they're usually
in better okay this is a question for
everyone do you think roles reverse that
women are happy when they're younger
yeah yes and then less happy yeah I mean
why do you think why do you think women
why do you think women spend three
hundred thousand dollars in their
lifetime on beauty products that's the
number one thing that women out like
outspend men in why do you think women
spend so much money on Botox lip filler
all that stuff they're trying to look
young I'm sorry I'm sorry I think
innately innately women know it listen
we just we just heard the pattern like
China China just gave you the gold fact
pattern of what how it goes and we skip
past it so quickly we didn't even tell
that's the pattern right there that's
what happens
um okay so those questions asked after
that which is like no one understood
that he just answered everything so
basically I'm not I'm not miserable I'm
[ __ ] happy man sorry I don't hardly
swear but you know what it is I'm just
happy Life's good like so I don't
understand my girls in the early 20 I
just like my life is really good so this
thing where they want to act like men no
we're living our life and and and it's
the women are getting the 30s that
trying to make it fair they're trying to
make it no but it doesn't have to be
fair because it wasn't fair for us early
and then we had to go through life it
not being fair eating [ __ ] not being
looked at but now we're not eating [ __ ]
we're eating caviar on steak you know
what I'm saying say to you and yeah okay
okay
um
so I I have a question for the men
um do you prefer female leadership male
leadership or do you not have a
preference
I don't I don't have I don't have a
preference but I do know that I have
experienced both
okay I don't care but I've got I don't I
don't have a preference I've got I've
got mentors
um who everything I learned
professionally like I'm indebted to them
forever
um
want like two of them are women one's a
one's a man but yeah I don't have a
preference up you know I love them all
the same
have you ever seen someone at work get
falsely accused of essay yes let me tell
you something very quickly on that
so sorry I Breathe Into the camera
um at my at my at my last my last job
when I was an employee
um
so
there was there was like a weird
um situation going on where if if anyone
told if anyone knows me I I just I told
the truth like that's that's what I'm
that's what I'm known for yeah that's
what my channel is about 100 interviews
go and check that out on YouTube
um so basically
it does offend people sometimes you know
some you know people want to hear nice
things but unfortunately I wish I could
you know the truth was always nice but
it's it's not I'm just the messenger I'm
just gonna tell you what it is but
unfortunately sometimes it's gonna make
people uncomfortable so this was
happening at work and the HR lady
um did not uh love the fact that I was
doing this and highlighting certain
things so she tried to put me under
something called a performance review
um and started trying to like follow me
like outside of work I just I turn I
turn and see uh certain places like all
of a sudden she's on my same tube into
work and weird little things that I
thought I kind of fought nothing of and
then
um one day she called me into a meeting
it was just me and her in the room
and I was she she said to me
um she said she said something about
black people yeah
um which I know is not the topic but
immediately in that moment I resigned I
had to I resigned the job
um and but the way I did it the way I
did it because it's just me and this
lady in the room I'm a big black guy
I very very carefully said to her with a
smile on my face I would like to resign
it's not you yeah it's not you it's it's
all good
um but I've been thinking about it for a
while
um I've already written a letter I
hadn't
um I'll say I'll send it to you later on
I just I'd like to resign I think I'm
ready to move on with a smile
walked out the room and then went and
made sure I was somewhere where everyone
could see me and started to explain to
one or two of my colleagues what
happened uh and then shortly after that
I moved on because I know that if I had
not
um for some reason I felt like if I
hadn't handled that situation in that
way that woman could have come out of
that room and said anything
about me doing essay or anything to her
in that room and
you know I I'm not aware though not that
I look like a weirdo or nothing but you
know it's not hard for someone to say oh
look at this poor
um
um you know little white woman and this
big black guy and it's it's believable
if someone says something about like
about me
um something about me like that it's
believable look at the size of me you
know what I'm saying so I had to handle
that situation very carefully and use my
wits
um so yeah I just wanted to tell that
that story very quickly on that point
and but did she accuse you of something
or no no no no she she couldn't because
the way I did it okay yeah the way I did
it she couldn't there was no cameras in
that room but the way I kind of smiled
and
you know made her just made her
comfortable and then but Alex yeah what
was the Assumption what was the
assumption that she could say that about
you he was safeguarding it's like so
almost safeguarded do you know do you
know what it is yeah I'm I've just see
I've seen enough situations
what have you seen enough situations
like that where people
so I learned from other people's
mistakes and it's and it's not a
person's mistake sorry bro it's not a
person's mistake to not look out for the
lie that's coming against them but it's
it's still I learned from that situation
and decided exactly how I was gonna
handle you know that situation at that
time women are spiteful I've heard guys
talk about how they were accused of
essay after they rejected a girl and
like there is there's one case in the
U.S where a girl accused a guy of sa and
um they they kicked him out of the
school even after footage came out of
her him in to kiss her at the bar her
pulling him back to the dorm and like
clearly like flirting with him all over
him all night and then
like he still got kicked out of the
school even with all that evidence and
footage that came forward that's the
problem like it's easier for women to
play that card than it is for men like
men don't have any sort of backup on
that topic and that happens every day so
what he's saying like I completely
understand
what about you China yeah so I know so
many um I could give you examples of
this but what so it's you know I'll say
remember the story that I told you I'm
not going to speak about that but I'm
actually um I'm actually writing a play
about something like something about
this we're gonna put it on next year so
when it yeah as we get through I'll let
people know but there's actually a story
that I'm writing about it's quite it's
quite poignant and so I'm putting we're
gonna put on um uh stick on on a theater
production of it next year uh so but
what I will talk about I'm gonna talk
about a friend of mine's case I'm not
going to speak too much about him
because I don't want to let it go but
what I will say is a friend of mine was
working he had a very good job
um in the educational sector
um
he was uh there was a new role that's
about to come out he there was a
colleague of him like they used to have
a bit of Bounce but it was nothing you
know I'm trying to say to you he went
for a job role she went for a job role
he was given the job role she was not
given a job role everything was fine I
put to that point after that point he
was given the job role he obviously
became a boss and then now he had to get
to do certain things and you know what I
mean so she didn't like the fact that he
was given the job role and he was now
her boss even though they were fine 100
before everything was fine she started
creating problems within it and saying
that she can't work with him and then
obviously the um hatred was like why
can't you work with him and then she
came around he's been inappropriate and
that created a whole spiral of events
that happened and when I know how hard
my boys come from nothing it's not one
of the it's one of these people that's
come from nothing like war-torn country
to climb up and to get yourself go to
university get yourself an educational
sector and he was like the only black
person in there and then she was also um
she was a black girl mate so it's got
and then those are two of them and when
she went and made whatever allegations
against him it set a whole spell of
events that put him through and I had to
witness this man go through this pain
like and he's my friend and I was just
like why is she doing this but she just
didn't like the fact he got the job and
she didn't get the job
um
in the end he had to go on some HR
course about inappropriate conduct at
work he he kept his job and everything
was fine but you see after that he um he
left he left the post and went somewhere
who just like bro it wasn't the same he
was like I didn't want to climb up any
higher in that industry even though that
they they found me it was not guilt but
everything was fine just the fact that
he had to be put through that that whole
process so you see what he's saying Alex
he's saying I
see as a man
and when you put yourself in a scenario
that's why I said don't move to girls I
don't because I could never have a woman
say to me that I came and approached the
inappropriate because I don't even do it
so I'm saying to she's gonna have to
approach to me when you see the messages
between us two it's not going to be me
that's trying to say it's going to be
her because we live in a new world now
and I've always been like this but ever
since women have said oh you know what
if a man's walking down the road I
expect him to cross over this over the
road because it makes me feel nervous
I'm I'm minding my business you know I
got my hoodie on I'm I'm doing my own
thing but now I'm saying that but I what
women are these okay okay you're saying
what women are these just saying no but
the same women that are talking about
the rubber necking or cat these that's
nice I mean I say women that would be
myself are you referring to myself no so
you asked me a phantom you asked me a
question and I'm speaking so you're
saying which women are doing this you
talked about the advert right the same
women that are talking about the advert
are the same women that are making a man
cross over the road because personally I
would never I didn't say you I didn't
say you see what we're doing is you're
making it about you stop making it about
trying not to out but you're making it
about you I'll give you an example that
definition of sexual assault and it says
for example pressure
there we go so manipulation bullying
intimidation threats deception drugs or
alcohol they're trying to include if a
guy
the stupidest [ __ ] I've ever heard of my
life if a guy lies to a girl about his
job and she sleeps with him like
thinking he has that job they're going
to say that's essay
I understand I understand where they got
it from in terms of
if obviously you know I mean like that's
the level of manipulation if someone did
something obviously it's not good but if
someone slept with somebody based on
what they thought they worked as and
then they found that they didn't it's
like I wouldn't call it essay though I
call that an l no no
I would as well I wouldn't call it
I wouldn't call it SAE by passing me but
I understand where they tried to put
into the category yeah from it's a form
of manipulation but that's not sexual
assault though sorry but what it is is
like the sexual assault comes from if
you've told me you don't if you know
that you're gonna tell me you're a bin
man I don't care let's give a real like
if someone was to say Ben man oh you
just did something I mean Council work
or whatever it is I don't care
personally I'm not discriminative or
prejudice against anyone on their work
but like if you told me that's what you
did I would take you as that and I'll
take you from that but if you've had to
lie to me to tell me you do something
else for me to take because this is not
you you're on the bus stop in my vagina
trust me
but you see where the men are coming
from it's like like if a guy tries to
convince you to sleep with him that
could be seen as coerced that's creepy
right I I understand like okay like I've
seen I I think every girl has had an
experience with a guy that's like too
pushy right but there's a difference
between pushy and sexual assault yeah
and I just think recently in recent
years we've been blurring the lines to
the point it's confusing confusing and
men like China are like you know what
screw this every girl's different every
girl is gonna one girls one girl's gonna
report me one girl's not one girl's
gonna think this is flirting one girl's
gonna report me for assault that they're
just like you know what [ __ ] this I
don't even want to deal with it and
that's why men don't it's fine for you
not me I'm like I want to be a boy stop
with these oh my God so
in fact for everyone for everyone so so
if uh if the if a Bim man said you know
lies and says I'm a doctor you know oh
I'm Michael Jordan himself or whatever
yeah
um and he's Prime yeah and a girl sleeps
with him because of that
and then found finds out she was lied to
is that is that is this is there
something a bit
but women women catfish every day with
Botox lip fillers
can I get to the
actual question yeah I've presented it
but let me let me ask the question is
there
any kind of
responsibility or is there is there
anything weird about the girl choosing
to sleep with someone because of this
state is so title or whatever is there
any wrong there yeah
no no I'm asking you a question I'm
asking I'm asking a question we've just
presented that women are not good bosses
women are not good leaders therefore men
have to do it so if you don't have the
leadership skills for most women
yeah but you have to lie and say a not a
bit because you're not proud I would I
mean I could be with a bin man if you
say it with chess
I don't think I don't think my question
is being understood so but gone Karen
you know what you're saying you're
saying that why if a woman has sex with
a man because of his title yeah isn't
that a form of manipulation but why did
the man lie about his title because he
knew that woman not me but that woman
cared more about the title than the
person cool let's get to that let's
let's definitely the right one hold on
hold on hold on let's definitely get to
the man lying because that's wrong okay
cool but what about the what about step
one of the woman sleeping with the man
because like okay let's let's take let's
have an example let's take the tender
swim there it wasn't just one woman yeah
that was many like he was doing that
everywhere but he was picking a specific
sorry to cut you if I was but I feel
like he was picking a specific type of
women a woman sorry so like women that
were not you know he knew they had money
he'd done his research he's not gonna go
talk to their breakfast no I'm not a
great woman but he was making sure that
they was you know single he'll make sure
that they was kind of you know you know
in a country that had good credit yeah
you know that you know what I mean he
was picking wisely so he targeted he was
targeting women that he knew were
vulnerable and that's like that's a
different type of you know manipulation
in a sense but what we're saying is like
if a guy's got a job and you're happy
with your job and you want to set a type
of girl I feel like you should present
yourself as that person just be real to
yourself I agree with you but his point
is is it's a question is there anything
wrong with women sleeping with a man
just for his time
is the only wrong in that situation okay
sorry my point was so so wait wait let
me let me just clarify it there's two
steps here there's two there's two
things here
let me I'm gonna give it to her she has
to finish
so Step One is the man the man lied
about his um status yeah yeah step two
is the woman slept with him because of
his status are are they both wrong or is
it is it only the man that's wrong I
think he's wrong for lying because I
think everyone should be their authentic
self we only get one life two a woman
should be allowed to sleep with whoever
she feels like has a certain status
because men do the same like they don't
sleep well if a woman's at home
but I'm saying I'm saying women men
don't sleep with women for status they
sleep with they sleep with women for
beauty and arguably women
um choose more for beauty than men do um
they're much more picky on their way but
they're wait they're much more picky on
dating apps and like even when they when
they study like women on a track like
women rate 80 of women is unattractive
oh sorry man sorry so the equivalent the
equivalent for a man would be is it
wrong for a man not to sleep with a
woman who's not beautiful or a woman who
hasn't had makeup or woman has and had
surgery do you get what I'm saying to
you men look for different things women
look for different things I think
everyone should just go for whatever
your preference again can we can we
really say to men be Arthur okay wait
can we can we really say to man be
authentic when again women women the
Instagram filters the botox the lip
filler the the chin implants the Chicken
Plants all the modifications that women
tend to do or have done and I feel like
they're very visible and men are aware
of them that's the whole difference yeah
but guys use steroids there's a way
there's an awareness I feel like there's
an awareness when it comes to women
because we're very like fooled with
certain things men have a bit more
strategy when it comes towards how they
would like to find a woman or to get
what they would lack from a woman so
that comes down to them telling them
this job or accidentally drive this car
or they dress fancy for a specific type
of I've seen guys
which do you think is more common I men
lion
if you guys want to do this we can do
this but what before we can do this
it's not even War but I would need
everyone to take off their makeup I will
need everyone to take out any hair which
is not their natural hair anything on
your nails which is not yours will need
to do that if you've got Botox in there
we have to squeeze it all out yeah I
mean no no no no so don't forget lip
filler
basically basically and then what's
wrong what's wrong with lip filler hold
on hold on a second if you're gonna say
that's a lie then everything you guys
are doing is a blatant lie we can see
the light but yet we allow it because
you know I mean this is what I'm trying
to say so wait hold on hold on a second
um
so
the better question would be the reverse
of it
if a woman lies about her body count
yeah is that not manipulation and then
if I find out you've lied about your
body count to me it is equal to you a
man lying about his status or my about
his job because for men for men body
count is way more important so I know a
man that got me yes I know a man yes it
is it is it's very important and the men
that say it's not important is because
they don't hang around to be a husband
they just run up your body count and
give it to the next guy so anybody
wondering so I can no no I'm saying so
any guy that says body count is not
importance because he doesn't have good
intentions for you why would he say it's
important when he's about to go to a
next girl do you understand but I
promise you this the woman he settles
with he's gonna find it very important
so if we're going to say that it's a
manipulation tactic for men to talk
about are to to you know if he's a bin
bin guy and he says a footballer but you
still sleep with him like he said why
are you sleeping on someone like that
but if we're gonna do it the opposite
way round then if women lie you need to
It's like white thing at home yeah so
basically if you lie about your body
count if you lie about your body count
then I find out I don't care if it's
five years six years we can have a kid
you're going do you know why you're
going because my relationship was built
upon a lie the same way you slept with a
guy that was built upon a lie before you
can say to men what you're saying make
sure you're not lying about anything and
a lot and right now lies Eliza light and
right now a lot of you girls are lying
on here
who does who does which more do women
lie about their body counts more often
than men lie about their jobs
I'm talking about personally as a whole
like generalization like as men
sometimes they do have like you know
like you would say like paid like good
work and paying jobs whereas in the
council with I don't know 500 000 more
than women yeah I feel like men do that
because they need to uphold the status
like in in a lot of men's minds they
look they're meant to be the home
bringer right but my point is like who
lies about which more everybody lies man
what's your body things what's your body
count
okay forget that would you tell somebody
that you're just meeting or just
beginning today your body count I've
never lied to
um a boyfriend about it good like I I
just I feel like you should be honest
like the guy was like approaching you
was kind of like never tell no random
guy never here but like people scared to
me like maybe he's your boyfriend a
couple times
you tell him but he won't become your
man unless you tell him your body count
not as you just said no no no no so okay
okay so listen if I'm dating you we're
dating for six months seven eight yeah
okay and you ask me no first of all
there's another energy that we do you
see a lot of times of men we don't have
to ask because we can feel the energy
you know you know you can feel the
energy right A lot of times when the
girls had a lot of bodies they come with
a lot of trauma and it and it comes out
in the way they interact with men you
can feel it the room can feel it the
energy is so when we feel this we know
so we already know this is not gonna be
a long-term thing but then there's other
ones you can't necessarily and you're
like you're gonna give the girl the one
opportunity and I say I want to feel
like Kanye this the reason I say I want
to feel like corn is because when Connie
married Kim he knew egg listen he knew
exactly what he was getting into this is
why I don't if you cry if he's crying
now you're crying what are you crying
for bro you know what he's doing here so
that means that he could not step into a
room and he did not know nothing about
about her so no one could come and
embarrass her a lot what a lot of girls
do is they like a guy and then they
don't want to tell the full truth so
they start the relationship built upon a
lie but the thing about lies is you know
what you know what I'm trying to say to
you what's done I'm trying to work out
who these women are because I'm not that
one I'm not calling you that but most
women okay okay some women a lot of
women lie about the body counts due to
the fact that they don't want to be seen
as what men do as well no but okay so
why why is that whenever a man make a
statement about women we have to say
butt man
okay no I'm saying but we do like so
it's just you know it's true
what I mean is it's equal okay so
equally we do the same thing okay so I
don't think like I don't think if
anything sometimes if anything men were
like up about their body count so so
yeah so the thing about it is yeah women
control access to sex men control access
to relationships so
I'm filled with a beautiful panel of
guests right I'm sure any one of you
guys will not have problem getting men
to sleep with you and if you say you
you've got your capping because I can
just know that already right because
you're all beautiful women right but I
don't have I won't be able to have as
much sex as you will be able to have all
you have to do is literally say to a guy
you can go on social media now say to
God yeah well there you go right do you
know what I have to do to no come on
after putting that work in that Finance
right all I gotta do is walk outside
yeah
well that's what they say women get what
they want and men get what okay so so if
we deal with that yeah that means you
are having sex whenever you want with
whoever you want versus I'm having sex
whenever I can get with whoever give it
to me completely different thing right
so if we look at that then wow women's
body count can be but imagine yeah so
going back to your point about you said
about the body count thing right so
someone that I used to date he said to
me that it only matters to him as long
as I have got with his friends what do
you think about that that's wait can I
can I give you a quick just um I asked
guys this question on my show all the
time would you rather have a girl that
has five bodies but you know two three
of them or a girl with Tony but a girl
with 20 but you don't know any of them
and they all say 20 buddies yeah yeah
they all say 20 and I don't want 20
bucks because loyalty well it's just
more like guys don't want to be
embarrassed like the biggest thing they
wouldn't be enough to own it well it's
just like it's kind of embarrassing for
a guy to walk into a room and know that
three of his friends hit or like exactly
yeah so it's embarrassing so you have to
remember body count doesn't matter in a
lot of situations so sex is invasive
right slept with my friends I don't
think I don't think body Count's the
only thing but but
um but it matters and that's the thing
like if you go from if you're a virgin
and there's different studies that I'll
give slightly different numbers but I'm
just going to use them this one just as
an example
um if you slept with if you're a virgin
on your wedding night you have an 80
chance of a happy marriage drops down to
25 percent if you've slept with more
than five most guys would pray for five
nowadays and and there's some studies
that say as a virgin at 60 70 I know
people will come for me on that but but
the the point is still the same you're
more likely to have happy marriage if
you're a virgin then if you're then if
you slept with more than five it's like
five to seven seems to be when you're
ruined as a woman statistically is that
because you don't know any better due to
experience yeah yeah
no it's because basically like like the
guys that are the No No the guys that
are the best most girls can't lock down
because how did they get to be the best
they have a lot of girls
and if they're good in bed like how many
girls you think are calling them and so
like that's why the the equivalent like
that's why I say like they women swipe
right five percent of the time and they
hate men because they're all sleeping
with the same one because it's again 100
of women want 20 of men and sometimes
some people argue it's five percent of
men like what percent if you want a guy
that's over six foot what percent I need
you to cough out of the mic I'm sorry
um like what percent of men do you think
are over six foot fifteen percent but
don't you think that's creepy because as
females in general get older of course
we're going to have more experiences so
why is it you have to have this
completely pure image like we're not a
little girl but why of course but the
the problem is is that you're not
satisfied and the older you get you
can't keep those guys anymore so by 30
you've lost 50 of the options that you
had at 20. so on dating apps like
they'll say this many guys swiped right
on you it goes down by 50 at 30.
and and so the guy that the guy so the
guy the not really um the guy because
guys will filter you out based on age
because they just think the women their
age like they don't want to deal with
they don't want like kids they don't
want an ex-husband they don't want that
stuff and so it's like then the guy at
20 that you know or 25 whatever it was
um that that you keep thinking about you
can't keep
I think it's just double standards on
this one you're right it is a double
standard but it goes back in biology you
can't change the things that men want
like like the reason that a low body
count matters is because
um historically they had to ensure
paternity so if a girl was sleeping
around like um paternity tests are new
like that's a new phenomenon that that
wasn't there throughout history so
um they didn't want to pass on resources
to a kid that wasn't theirs the same way
like most women want a guy they're
height or taller would any of you date a
guy five inches shorter than you
okay possible but but not common right
the most most women like if they dated a
guy shorter than them it was one to two
inches it wasn't significant and so
that's because historically you needed a
guy to protect you and you can't get rid
of that like but you can't get rid of
your biology yeah but po look how easy
it is for gold to say I won't date a guy
that's
um five inches smaller than me but if I
say I don't want a date a girl that's
fat people start getting mad but you're
entitled to your own no no but generally
people be like oh fat shaming but I'll
be but you can change your weight you
cannot change your height like you're
born that way so if you shame a man for
his height what can he do but if we say
to lose some weight you can actually go
and do something so I just think like a
lot of times women's you can earn more
money but you can't reduce your body
count
okay I'll be honest
[Applause]
you can't she can't change that yeah
what's happened it's happened but you
can earn more money so the same argument
that you're saying that a woman can lose
weight but a man can't grow taller it's
the same thing there's certain things
that are restricted but were still
judged upon no but based on the biology
of what we want no matter but your body
count is your choice yeah so like that
that you had a choice in man don't have
a choice
not necessarily true though okay so
we're not talking about great okay okay
just in terms of like okay I need you to
if you're gonna talk I need you to talk
into the mic because it's just okay
we're just saying with it that body
count like sa like what if you okay
we're talking about the rule not the
exception yeah so we'll never so if that
happens we're never talking about that
just you know we know about those
scenarios we know about it but but like
when we speak about this we're talking
about consent consent yeah so we can
take essay out of that because we're not
speaking about that we we understand
that right because if we do then we'll
just keep going everywhere we're talking
about consenting everyone we're talking
about a consenting woman that chooses to
sleep with 20 men cool versus a man who
is born that way and cannot change you
you chose to open up your legs of 20 men
he cannot choose his height so it's not
the same
I feel like maybe some women maybe some
women maybe a little bit you have to
tell them sorry sorry guys I feel like
maybe some women may be a little bit
bitter or upset because obviously
um men will advertise men will advertise
one thing but want something different
would give attention to one thing but
want something different like I've
witnessed personally like
guys putting up loads of captions every
day or every other day about loyalty
hoes hoes loyalty homes
but they like I know of certain people
they are attracted
which they may know or not know
to the hose for one night stands not for
a while I'm not saying to wife but
they're but like the attention they're
giving this hope yes
the effort they're giving this hoe the
attention they're giving this hoe the
entitlement yes it's for the pumps I
understand Pearl
um yes it's for the
for the one hit whatever but as wifey me
watching that Pursuit and then watching
him pursue me
I'm just gonna be like do you know what
you're doing no your wifey he's all so
women have to understand women have to
understand the difference between men
wanting sex with you versus wanting
actual commitment with you yeah I
understand that's the difference but
sometimes it looks I know I know I know
but it's not the same trust me because
the outcome is no it's been put out the
pursuant might be but the outcome is
different so when men all chase after
these girls yeah versus you you're like
oh it meant he said he don't like her
but why is he liking the pictures why is
he doing these sorts of things that's
because he wants one thing what you need
to do is you need to separate yourself
from those goals so we get a lot of good
girls that chase the top 20 or bad boys
right so when you're a good girl what
actually happens is when you chase these
boys you don't actually become a good
girl anymore you just become the same as
one of these hoes because what you're
doing is you're putting yourself step by
step next to holes and you're saying oh
why won't he pick me or why is he
treating that these are holes they're
always going to be holes and this is
what they're gonna do and good girls
have always been on the other side and
holes have always been on that side but
the problem is good girls are now
looking at holes and be like why are
they get why the holes getting love
they'll hold that's it we staying strong
it's like it's a meeting strategy for
men it's like men are men are like
they're biologically predispositioned to
like screw as many girls as possible so
like though they're it's crazy if you
talk to like men about their attraction
floor and like what girls they find like
there'll be girls that like I do not
think like a guy would find attractive
but like at their attraction floor if
you got one thing if you got one body
part that's good they're into it like
it's just yeah that's true
um I'm gonna take a second to read super
chats
um I apologize if any of these are mean
I'm just the messenger
um uh guys like the video there's over
3000 of you in here watching live um so
make sure you guys like the video that
is the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these um to
push out these live streams make sure
make sure you subscribe to the channel
too because we're trying to get to 750
000 subscribers okay
um the UK Economist would guess one
their daughter to sleep around with many
men or wait until marriage find a good
husband and get commitment is the red
Tel 9265 is the red dress planning on
talking today
um
Wendell coven women have unrealistic
expectations um not standards Mo Blitz
the black girl on the couch and the girl
behind her need therapy Pearl there
these are examples of 304s you can't
touch men pay attention run away from
304s they're these kind of 304s that
expect men to be perfect
nefarious um take off your makeup lip
fillers bbls hair pieces a lot of you
are lying on here mic drop moment
respect to China Pearl please um archive
to rumble two and keep up the off some
work I think we're on are we on rumble
or we're on something one of the one of
those platforms are we on Rumble oh yeah
I guess we're on Rumble maybe put the
link in the description guys okay see
matherson
um the lady deserves um the lady
deserves a essay claim for that weave of
hers Wendell coven I find it funny that
women shake their heads in disagreement
when men tell you how we see things how
many times do we say the same things 90
Frito pie campman
women can't be men when they can't
answer a yes or no question C Matheson
Cult of womanism will do anything to
protect itself from accountability
Fishbowl so our push-up bras and plastic
surgery sa now see Dumbledore women who
think that being a mother is so
difficult or so difficult or pathetic I
raise my three daughters and parenting
them as the easiest is the most Pleasant
part of my life it's only hard if you
are deeply selfish Daniel
um Can the blue jumpsuit babe do a 360
real quick 90 free-toe pie what's the
difference between women being sexist
and racist in both situations they are
judging the hole for what a minority did
Omi Design Studio send the asteroid
after listening to delusional women
there's no hope for society to flourish
I'm ballin you have scars from the
police at 15 what did you do in that
scenario zero accountability police
don't randomly beat up 15 year olds
unless they're committing crimes and
resisting arrest Adam Sutton sorry about
every time China talks I cringe he
articulates arguments so poorly and
barely processes what people say to him
amen Dana to staff you won't be heard if
you don't quit bullying The Bullying
tactics claims that aren't established
aren't proven it can't be it can't be
proven reported anyway talk like you
have some sense if you can't handle the
convos quit it um 90 free to apply Pearl
I know it's your show but if I could
offer some advice ice when asking
questions before they ask ask answer
them or have them repeat the question
the UK Economist I've been assayed by
two College age girls who punt pinched
my bum does the panel think that men can
be essayed too wolf art de Leon content
gold tell pink top she's now famous Joe
Pio when you are what you are skipping
over is the ones that want is that one
likes to likes cat calls and the others
consider it essay essay ones mix it in
with grape and essays and Essay stories
hence the 89.9 percent a 90 free-toe pie
men are bears women are salmon covered
in Honey see Dumbledore today's women
aren't educated they're indoctrinated
the shaming language is over the top
like Kevin used to say shame insult
guilt and need to be right is strong
with these 304 zh Pearl cleat please
check your email if you're looking for
more video editors great show anyway we
are looking actually for um I think
we're gonna need a second part-time
editor so yeah yeah feel free or email
me or DM me on Instagram I'm
justperlythings gmail.com Joe Pio 89.9
percent of men essay so destructive how
do women do great and insult men like
it's a normal conversation I buy flowers
for a girl and she's in love girl b
files a restraining order for essay
brainwashed
um Daniel um the guy in the black Tech
has the right idea but he lacks the
conversational tactic and emotional
intelligence listen to understand not to
respond Daniel um grape has physical
trauma signs 9 out of 10 and develops a
behavioral profile and creates an adult
trial report it the state can take it to
court Without You memo after dark the
point of reporting it is to start an
investigation that way evidence can be
found too many women lie about sexual
assault it makes me sick if you truly
thought someone committed such a heinous
crime you'd report it Doug MPA showing
my support for the mandem's voice my G
China China is about to blow up the game
let's go
um okay so I'm gonna go back to the
original topic um
okay
um
um okay have you guys seen any
procedures or policies put in place to
put more female leadership in place
where you work
I had to think about it and I was like
oh well at my workplace I'm a senior
waitress which is like headweight
waitress or wait taught in in the front
house of in front of house there's other
women that also um have well there's
another lady should I say that is also a
head waitress as well but apart from
that is Mills and just smells and
there's any other one female manager and
I believe that she's been combated by
two other males so are you even relevant
we're not sure but um I just feel like
women are given are being given more um
positions but I'll be being trusted with
the positions that we've been given
that's the problem imagine giving me a
job and you've employed me knowing that
this is the um this is my experience and
then still somehow questioning my
experience it's like do you not know
what you employed me for did they employ
you or whoever it was because they were
a woman or because they're qualified
um I feel like they employed employed me
myself because they needed someone to be
like off that level of you know
experience in Calabar in their
establishment and they had a lot of male
counterparts already so they wanted to
even out and obviously I'm black and you
know the hierarchy you know you have to
have like gender fluid was it to fill a
quota I feel like yeah there was making
you know filling out the stuff but at
the same time they needed it to be in
the hierarchy they really had a male one
so it was like to even out but like I
said them giving me that position for me
felt like okay they're trying to make it
more fluid to the other ladies there
that okay you know it's possible because
I feel like before they employed me
there was something they could have
given it in like you know pay rides they
could have gave them a you know a little
job rise whatever but they didn't they
put a new person there so at times yeah
I feel like women are being given extra
you know position but just I'll be being
trusted with the position that we've
been given okay what about you
um they want to hear you speak
um what was the question again um oh
have there were there any policies put
into place to put women in more
leadership positions where you work
um the last job that I had like an
actual nine to five
um one girl wanted to go as a business
manager but they made her work for it
for about two years and they kept giving
it to other men while she was waiting
for it so I feel like it's less chance
that you're gonna get a higher position
as a woman because of the things that we
discuss so no policies
it sounds like there weren't any where I
was no and there wasn't it
history it's not really it's not really
applied to me because I work for myself
and I've only worked for the one woman
so I'm not sure but Cleo I'm sure has
in short yes I feel very blessed where I
work they do open it up for different
Creeds colors ages demographics and they
like to have a 50 50 gender split within
our meetings and Leadership and they try
to um okay they try to make it 50 50.
okay go ahead
yeah I think
um her mic I think is muted blessing
um yep on okay I think with my previous
one it's it was a thing where like in
meetings we did talk a lot about okay
when the next event happens we need more
female leaders to speak up and like kind
of take control a bit more so it's not
as male dominated so yeah I think it's
getting a bit more evened out okay um so
what they were specifically trying to
get women in yeah so in a lot of the
meetings they would say yeah we want a
lot more females to speak up like when
we do events and whatnot so yeah okay
um but let's start on that side or um
China go and then anywhere you've worked
have they tried to put policies in place
to get more women yeah in the past I've
um because yeah in the film and security
industry they've tried to get women into
more
um insecurity yeah in the film because
not represented enough you need to have
a certain amount of women women there
yeah
but it's not yeah yeah yeah
I have I have a friend yeah yeah mankind
men can't search woman so obviously
women obviously like if the scenario in
a woman's toilet or something like that
you need you need to have women's
security yeah it doesn't mean they're
going to do the same thing that men are
gonna okay
[Laughter]
um go ahead
um like I said I'm not that experienced
in like the working industry but it's
always been 50 50. okay there's always
women Amanda okay
are there any policies in place I've
never been aware I've heard that there
are some but I've never been nowhere
okay yeah I'm very limited also okay any
policies that were put in place policies
must be invisible I ain't seen it I
ain't seen them pearly I don't know
maybe they're in the back I haven't seen
them
um go ahead
um in my industry of work
um they mainly
employ or women mainly apply for like go
forward for those roles so if anything
it's about equality and diversity so
evening it out and looking for men
potentially okay
um
there are policies put into place to put
women in leadership can we say there's
anything holding women back from doing
any job in 2022
no okay no kids
yeah okay what about you guys who said
yeah I said yeah but I'll say I'm
personal life choices I feel like what
you want to do in your life and where
you want to go is what you will
fluctuate more towards so some women
that have much ambition not to say that
you know anyone's ambitionist but some
people just want to do the mainstream
they don't want to exact themselves
further or broaden the Horizon that's
why I feel okay go ahead you too
yeah I think mostly women don't really
want to do those roles because this is
like generalized because they're harder
jobs and women prefer the easier life
what was the question again exactly
sorry can we say that women are held
back from doing any job in 2022 when
their specific policies to help women
and there's nothing stopping us from
applying from any job I was just going
to say I think if the only thing
nowadays especially in like the Western
World the only thing that hold women
back is themselves maybe you know
whatever their home life is or you know
whatever limiting beliefs they have
around having such a high-paid job
yeah I
I've always done what I wanted in my
career I've always as an out of tanned
every now into a year so I take it as a
challenge personally if they tell me no
then I'm like watch me yeah great
yeah
um second real girl I kind of
just
um to defend probably another side of it
sorry just adjusted the just to defend
another side of it I think maybe some
women may find it they may think it's
unattractive to another man to make more
money or be more successful so they may
not want to go for those job roles
because they may want the man to feel
like the man in the household and um
yeah making a lot of money is a skit as
a woman and having your own [ __ ] and not
needing [ __ ] much [ __ ]
um can be just hasn't can be very I've
been told
um scary or I think it's just the
attitude that comes with it I agree yeah
fairly you can come all sugary and sweet
with it and just kind of chill but some
women want to throw it in the man's face
like look at me I'm a workout I make
money money me yeah like if you if
you're the Breadwinners is your money
his money can you make the financial
decisions where's your money your money
um a few because like I said I but back
to my point before I trust men's
decision making I agree with you but you
I don't think that's common right yeah
it's not it's coming to me because I
live in my own world
um but yeah I trust male decision making
so I would be like oh babe I made this
whole heap of money maybe I'll say all
of the money I made juicy can I ask you
why do you trust me as leadership
um
and I haven't I haven't even grown up
with my daddy and I still do
um
like from visual experience it's less
hassle it's got less layers it's
clear-cut it's yeah less time consuming
and obviously I generally feel like men
are protective to me if obviously the
ones I'm attracted to do and I feel safe
around if I feel safe around you then
I'm gonna trust you're gonna make a
protective decision make like you're
gonna make a decision that's going to
protect both of us not saying I won't
but I'm gonna protect you in the uh
subconscious I'm gonna protect your
emotions I'm gonna protect how you may
not be seeing things looking at things
but on the physical maybe go get it is
there any other girls that feel like her
on a panel can you just put your hands
up
oh sorry and can I just ask can I just
ask you like can I ask you a bit so why
do you feel like that what trusting men
yeah why do you trust him in the man's
leadership
um I think men are more logical women
there's a lot of problems that come
along with their decision-making like
emotion and
I don't know I just I've always looked
up to men more than women generally
speaking because I feel like the
decisions they make pay off better
quicker decision making and I don't know
I just think the results are the results
show off much better than the decisions
that women make push
um I would say that my brain this is on
topic just to start this is on topic but
I'm going to start it sounding a bit off
topic my brain's a bit more um animated
so I see the way men think as a waffle
you know like squares
women think like spaghetti okay I'm with
you yeah so I'm hungry yeah you get it a
bit of food before but um you know like
when you tell a man something they will
execute it Box by box a female might be
because we're on the spaghetti route
we've probably gone down like we've done
Snakes and Ladders on you but you've
just done ladder did you get my plates
women we tend to add a bit more sauce to
the mixture but men keep it in line so
if I had money not to say I couldn't
spend it wisely but you might already
have something in place because you've
been doing that box box I've done it
scribble here scribble there I've done
it all over the place yeah you've done
it look babe
[Music]
but in a different manner you've
probably put into a better perspective
for me so I would give my trust more to
a man not to say that I don't trust
myself but I would rely or be open to
rely on his judgment based on the fact
that I I you know believe that he's got
this on board like he's with it right
here what about you why do you trust the
mental leadership
um I just think men are better at
certain things in general
um like I'll give you an example I want
a tan so it's a pretty big sample size
just like kids and most of my brothers
are engineers and like most of um me and
my sisters
um actually most of my sisters don't
have jobs yet but they won't be
Engineers like I just know them
um
but
I don't know I just think like with
money like especially with money um I
think just men tend to make better
decisions and the data supports it so
like women make 70 to 80 percent of
consumer buying decisions and like we
have more debt even though we make less
money and so to me that's just says like
women as a whole we make impulsive
emotional decisions in general and
there's some women that can kind of turn
that off but I don't think it's like
natural to us and that's why like they
most ad campaigns are targeted towards
women um so I think it's like a mixture
of just like data I've seen an anecdotal
experience where like male coaches I
have had overall you know there's the
one creepy one but oh one not 90
but overall have just been like better I
don't have to deal with like the drama
of you know the female coaches would
almost get involved in the team drama
and the males would just I don't know I
just think men are better at certain
things so is it like because you think
for men it's there they find it easier
to separate like emotion yeah and I can
see it in my because I one thing um I
talk about is I Outsource decision
making sort of like I have a manager um
you might have saw him use in the back
and like even my dad like those are the
two people I talk to about decisions
um and I honestly like trust them with
it because
it's it's like okay if you have to fire
someone in a business a woman's gonna
typically typically be more emotional oh
I don't like their family I don't want
to do it I don't want to fire them like
but a man is just gonna be like he's not
doing the job he's got to go and and I
had to have like that conversation with
my dad at one point he's like you should
have been done this already and it's
kind of like
like that I don't know I just think men
can like make decisions quicker where
like women will drag it out how much men
would call that woman that can make the
decision real fast
attractive and they wouldn't I I because
yeah no I I agree with you being that
woman imagine being that number of women
that men are not gonna even look at it
it's not really because of the decision
making it's because of like the traits
that are generally associated with it so
like like men want to come home and they
just want to feel like they're at peace
like they've been arguing with people
all day like they've been battling all
day they just want to come home and they
want to they want to have a woman that
just makes them feel good and be nice to
them but like those women tend to be
disagreeable they tend to want to argue
and they tend to want to disagree in any
decision he has to make like she's gonna
fight you on it like the woman that
wants to make decisions like they're not
quick to let their men make decisions
and like men want to be with a woman
that feels like like she trusts him so
um I said like for for us men when you
trust on the man's leadership it's the
ultimate
um
for us we feel like it's the ultimate or
we think it's the ultimate um showing of
love and submission and a lot of times
when people hear submission so
they want me to do that yesterday yeah
so they want me to use Cooperative
because submission tends to rub people
up the wrong way but I'm gonna use
submission by Cooperative because
when you submit to a man it doesn't mean
that it makes you it means you as a
woman it doesn't mean that you can I ask
you a random question because this is
based on what you're saying about okay I
was asked yesterday randomly someone was
like I don't think you'll be submissive
like how you're saying if all women will
submit someone said to me they don't
think I'll be submissive and I was like
why is that because I proved questions
and I was like you just I just don't
feel like if I wake up in the morning
you'd make me breakfast where have you
got this analogy so you looking at me on
that question yeah
it's not it's not that you don't it's
not I don't know what a breakfast cooker
looks like in the morning
maybe I would like that and I don't you
don't know that the happy person that
would do that and I'm like where's this
coming for you I I think I don't know
you personally but it's sometimes like
like girls that give off like the 50 50
mindset where it's like well why don't
you cook me breakfast or like they feel
like it should be 50 50 like I don't
know maybe you said something that will
not came off as like 50 50. so so what I
don't know however experienced you on
this platform today like I obviously
your opinionated and you're not you're
not scared to to part your views and
it's fine when a platform you should you
should do that but like what Pearl said
maybe just really want peace like you
can be the most intelligent woman I know
you're intelligent I know you could
listen you could be the top debate or
you could be doing but when I just come
home I beg you just oh wow I'll give you
this when you come home it wouldn't be
this actually no no but what I'm trying
to say to you is is we don't know we
just take you for how it is so we say
right if she
if I experience in a setting like this
then What's it gonna be like in a
relationship set and what's it give me
like we don't know what it is but the
bit that would attract me to you to
maybe get your number whatever you would
miss past that I'll be your loss
but what's my loss what's your loss it's
all about whatever it's not you're not
trying to say to you but it could be
avoided by you know what I'm like oh you
know what I wanted this platform and you
know she was a little bit but actually
like the energy like it's something I
have to like because I debate for a
living yeah but like it's something I
have to kind of like turn off sometimes
with the guys where I'm like oh I know
you're wrong but I just need to look
like like because men don't want to do
that they just want you to shut up and
be silent yeah I think there's nothing
there's nothing wrong with telling
someone when they're wrong whether
they're a man or woman but but in in
this scenario you know if you're gonna
tell a man that they're wrong it's not
about telling them they're wrong that's
that's fine it's just it doesn't need to
be done with like the you know the
attitude because of them but even even
even if you're smart like you're not you
know what sometimes the power in a woman
is black you know what I'm smarter than
him but I just let him have that and
you're just laughing with your friends
you're like
I just feel like guys like like if he
says something that's not statistically
accurate like he doesn't really want me
to like come in and give you all this
stuff like I just don't think he's good
oh what if there's a situation where I
because I I just men and women were
opposite so the man's been battling all
day battling battling verbally
physically and going against it now he
wants to get home and just feel woosah
the woman may have been
it's like suppressing suppressing all
day suppressing suppressing so for me
I've been all day trying to not be that
angry black girl now I come home I can
Dash my bag take off my wig
do you know what this woman said to me
and I had to smile between my teeth and
he's probably thinking Lord God no
that's well
but we're opposite so that's maybe why
it could Clash yeah no I've like talked
to guys about this and they just need
like a decompression time like they need
like 30 minutes straight in the door
yeah like to just and and honestly if we
can I think they preferred if we go to
our friends about like about little
stuff but like big problems if it comes
back to the trust and the decision
making well I'm saying most of my
friends are female which is highly yeah
but I want to trust a man right now it's
gonna be mine well I'm saying like Okay
does he really need to know that Tracy
at work was giving you the side act no
oh my God
I need a man to tell me okay I'm
basically going to my man saying babe
what should I do should I punch her
should I chill obviously sometimes I do
know the better option but I just need
your support so I I do think guys you
guys could correct me but if you say
like how do I address this situation I
think guys are problem solvers so
they'll help you fix it but I think as
women we don't want them to fit like we
just want them to listen yeah so so it
confuses them because we'll be like yeah
this [ __ ] at work she did this this and
this and then he said okay this is how
you solve it and we're like well no I
just like she still did this this year
you agree with me
I'll give you an example my dad like
I'll say oh this person I did this this
and he'll be like well just don't deal
with them anymore yeah excuse me
like literally what you're saying but I
like so what pear was saying is like us
as men we want to listen to your
problems but we don't really want to
listen to your problems so we get that
so so we want you to offload but after a
certain amount of time we're gonna we're
gonna want to give you a strategy to fix
this boss right but you don't want to
actually fix it you just want to moan
about your boss so at that point it's
kind of like
you have to go to your girls after that
because all you really want to do is
just talk right but us as men we don't
want to spend an hour talking about the
same thing we want to get to an end of
it and we want you to resolve it but
you're going to go back to your butt and
say to me the next oh you know what I
like my boss again I'll give you one
example there's some men that will
ostracize a woman from their friends
their family get them to themselves not
saying there's some that's what I said
some get them to themselves
um some men can do this without being
abusive they could just be selfish I
love my woman cool like you do you baby
um some people like them obsessed some
people don't and like now you've
ostracized her you're actually her
number one go-to and now you're telling
me I just want peace after you ostrich
no I don't think those types of men I
think okay if you're gonna talk about
that I don't think those types of men
talk to you told me Tracy's a whole you
told me my mommy
that's kind of on the woman like
sometimes I think like women kind of
like that drama because it's like you
put up with it if if you you picked them
you don't have to stay like why'd you
let him ostracize you know and I've been
I've been in a Sim I've been in a
similar situation but I'll take
accountability I think I did that I
think now I'm older I can see the
ostracization coming in but being for
younger females you don't have that much
perception on life yeah I think though
like sometimes guys just want to get you
away from your hoe friends
that I'm talking about come on guys
we're not but then your mama
guys that make you feel like you
shouldn't be talking to anyone else but
me you know someone's very like
obsessive like almost obsessive like
they don't need to be the only thing
when I've made you not my only thing
we'll be doing exactly see how you said
the same I don't think you should do
that like I he shouldn't do that yeah
but you see how he said the same
demographic of women that um would rub a
Nick are the same that thing I'm just
giving that example like a lot of guys
not all but a lot of guys that will be
like
a lot of guys that would find uh like oh
she's just bad telling me stuff she's
always coming to me telling me about her
this and that and that and this most of
those guys have ostracized that woman
and now they're asking for peace or some
men don't know how to create a peaceful
environment for the female and then
expect peace oh I just want peace no you
want someone to shut the [ __ ] up wait
did this did this happen to you yeah
yeah
it sounds really specific probably
somewhere subconsciously I'm not gonna
lie maybe maybe there's a little Vim or
maybe I just it may be a little bit of
me in a little bit of an observation
because I love to observe I just think
like you pick who you're in a
relationship with and I think there's
there's a group of girls that like to be
controlled like they just it kind of
happened to me it almost did like I I
was like hold on why don't I check my
mom's okay like I had to ask myself was
it the D a little bit was it the energy
so juice but then I realized he actually
cursed everybody out of my life
everybody like my friend he had a
problem with this person had a problem
with and obviously but it's a red flag
so so going up so so going on for me me
as a man I have no problem in in calling
out a man's bull or red flags or
anything like that like it's not
something I would have my sister
entertain it's not something I recommend
it's not something I recommend any woman
to do
um so if a man is trying to ostracize
you trying to alienate you from your
friends yeah these are these are all
types of controlling behaviors so yeah
it's not something I would support but a
man trying to get you away from that
whole friend Tracy no that's that's a
good man I'm being real
he's a good man
anyone's name who's Tracy is like excuse
me sorry trains you're a good girlfriend
I feel like most of this leads back to
communication they're like if you want
to vent to the guy that you're with just
ask him there's nothing wrong with that
same with like your friends like say if
I want to vent to my friends I'd be like
can I open up to you right now are you
in the right mind frame to hear from me
type thing there's nothing wrong asking
for communication the guy I'll let you
know and if it's not today then it might
be tomorrow or it might be the day after
like yeah reading the room and being
socially aware like you can definitely
know that your partner's like he's he's
not with it so yeah would you would you
um any of you girls would you would you
mind if your man cried to you okay to
cry to you cry yeah I wouldn't mind I've
had my partner of like nine years cry
I'll be like yes my babies
yes my baby needs me or your partner of
nine years no no no no no who said that
you said that yeah I've had I've been
with someone for nine years okay so I
have a question um you're not with him
anymore no I'm not who broke up with who
I would say I broke up with him he
should have cried every time
I know it's I know it's like every girl
that it's again it's not you yeah it's
basically proven no no I'm just
anecdotal no stops I've had girl after
girl come on my podcast and everyone
that says their boyfriend cried to them
I have a second question who broke up
with you it's always them but it always
depends on what wait he didn't cry in a
way of night he was actually being
emotional I was telling him listen I
don't know what you're doing right now I
gave him some facts but the situation
happens and I presented him with facts
and I was like this is what's going on
at your business and he the only way he
knew how to communicate was to break
down
at this point if I can do is
I broke up with him due to the fact that
I just feel like where you're trying to
go and where I'm going on two different
angles now before was on the same train
you jumped off and hanged out the window
and I like we didn't like you're doing
your own thing but he cried based on him
trying to be emotional and behind me
like f not kind of thing and he couldn't
control his emotions so his you know
what I'm saying and how long after did
you record no it was yes I would say
that he cried within the first year or
two of us being together and we spent
another four years if not five together
did you get it but he was doing like
other things so
that's that's the reason I know I just
don't think it's a coincidence but it
depends on how you cry though that's
what I'm trying to say all right but I
think a lot of times like women we don't
know what we want because it's like it's
kind of like how many times can a guy
cry till you like you know you didn't
cry that something
at some point no yeah we'll give you one
yeah
wait wait but if you wait come on that's
cap if he's crying every day you're
leaving
that's what I'm saying like the every
person's different and so you know at
some level like you're going to leave at
some point no for me I thought I forgot
cries it shows me that you have a level
or Consciousness consciousness of the
motion I can't be with someone that's
heartless just cold ruthless man you'll
just be like I don't cry just what is
that I think it's still human how would
you guys feel if your boss started
crying has that ever happened to you
female boss what male boss
nope no yeah I I didn't feel sorry for
you because
been spending too much people damn
business in this place and yeah what
goes around comes around and I looked at
you uh threw you a very small napkin
because I wanted to see fold it up and
let you be no no that's not what we're
about to do right um nope I've never
I've never seen it I've just heard
that's like a phenomenon like I've just
heard like girls in front of stress yeah
yeah yeah yeah
through my managers break down I feel
like we get emotionally like what's
overwhelmed women get overwhelmed
whereas men get angry I feel like men
cry from a part of their body they're
not used to hitting you know what I mean
that makes you come from a popular body
they've never hit before like no one's
ever hit you there so you're like what
feeling is this
no men can cry like but men men back out
inside
before your body creates those tears
you're bugging up internally trying to
understand what am I feeling yeah and
then your body's put into perspective
someone inside and he's crying then
that's an expressing and emotion but
like if he's crying because you won't
let him hit it then he's a cuisine
just kidding cry like
like I think at some point you get one a
year yes
that's a lie no but you know what life
is hot no but perfect crisis no for the
first time you've been honest for the
first time with
said exactly what you can do you can get
one a year with it's like what tends to
happen is we won't say you can cry maybe
one every other year
it depends on the topic like it's like
if if he like if he's going through it
like yeah a lot and like he's like going
through that emotion and if he's crying
I don't I think vulnerability can be
attractive in a way really then if he
doesn't fix his problems then he's still
crying
that's why I was going to ask I was
going to ask you so if he's crying like
he's like oh the first time he's going
through that he's crying every month to
um February's crying Wednesdays you know
what I mean at the same time
I'm gonna I'm gonna let you haven't
talked go ahead well I was just gonna
say yeah like obviously if they're
crying a lot over like something small
like Tracy was being horrible to me at
work fair enough you know it's so
ridiculous like all right I'm done with
this but in reality if it's a traumatic
experience someone's going through or
like something's happening and it's a
constant and sometimes their reaction is
to cry I don't think that is a sign of
weakness some is sometimes vulnerability
is strength every question I have a
question so let's say he he has as
whatever the situation is how how long
can you cry about it so he cries Monday
can he cry Tuesday well can you cry
Wednesday yeah honestly yeah if it's
something like it's like if you're just
crying about it and if you can do
something to change it it's like yeah no
let's say let's say he's depressed yeah
Monday
how how many days in a row can he cry
well this is the thing though I think if
it was anybody if they were relying on
me and they were constantly crying to me
for something that they're going through
internally I am happy to be someone's
shoulder to cry on however if however
actually crying and it's like they yeah
it's just it's like we can do these
things to help you this is a different
way of going through it it's just if
it's only crying nothing's happening
then it can be difficult on the other
person who's having to help them support
them so objection
listen
where's the camera
it's for men
a loss in your family loved one friends
cool
a movie that hit you deep and your eyes
water okay
that's it
that's a lot of pressure listen listen
this is real life yeah you have to be
a rock
you must you must don't ever ever
or do you respect or do you respect your
lovely girl we spoke before men
do not listen to that okay listen to me
yeah in a second one second one second
one second this is for the men I'm gonna
hand it back I'm not gonna talk too much
this is for the men real talk I'm not
trying to make people laugh
is real you most of you know that
already you know the struggles you know
what's going on you know what you gotta
do you don't have that time you can't be
doing that stay focused stay on your
purpose a loss cool
a sad movie that hit you somewhere cool
get back on job
that's it so I'm gonna just as a man let
me just add on to another man said so
yeah guys like this is to the men out
there
um do not cry to you don't cry well
because women as they find it very hard
to explain to you what it's okay to cry
about so the best thing to do is not to
cry so she said you can cry once a year
Pearl said um once every two years and
she basically said you can cry for about
three or four days but by the fifth day
if you're still crying out I'm not too
sure so this is a lot of mixed signals
for men so the best thing to do is like
what Alex says is just to be a rock and
I I'll be honest with you I'm gonna cry
no movies because because no no and but
he can give that to you family I pray
that we don't have to go through that
stuff but at that point you know men can
show emotion but I just think it's a lot
safer for men
just not quite brawl but I think I say
something okay
um I I personally think as a man if you
go to a woman and you're crying me I'll
lose respect for you it depends what
you're crying about like
um if it's a loss or something really
bad like of someone dying then yeah but
as a man I feel like it takes you off of
your purpose when you spend too much
time crying about things that you're
just wasting time and energy and I think
men really value respect and if my man's
crying often I'm gonna lose respect for
him I don't feel like that's a real man
like don't cry to me about it all the
time that's but that goes towards both
genders realistically don't sit and cry
about everything all the time
women women cry all the time over
everything yeah that's all you're doing
for it
other than the the gym and the pumps
where are you going to let this that's
what I was going to say
wait wait wait wait man can men can talk
to other men yeah
and Mendel and men don't really care if
they're girls crying over stupid [ __ ]
like they're kind of used to it we cry
over dumb [ __ ] like yeah we're dumb [ __ ]
all the time can men tell me where the
outlet is this is what I struggle as
somebody as I personally I'm a little
bit hesitant with men when it comes to
outlet like
um I just I just think it's other men
like I think men should go to other men
I think like women try to be mad that's
you and your woman mind which I
appreciate it's a beautiful I could tell
you
where is a man going to I'm going to go
to the gym
Alex is going to go to me and this is
what and then and then this is what's
gonna happen and then if I don't feel
like I can speak to Alex I want to speak
to blessing the blessing don't fool like
he can speak to um to me he's gonna
speak to Devante that the idea of this
is we're not supposed to speak to every
single man or cry to every single man
but if if my if Alex comes and cries to
me I know this is a very serious
situation because he's never cried and
men don't cry at that so I won't look at
it like how you look at it I'll look at
this at my boys got to a a level where
he's crying to me now we need to figure
out what's going on we need to come to a
resolution so crying to women
I will not lose respect for him in
actual fact I'm gonna gain so much more
respect for him because I know he's
showing me emotion he's never saw what
we've gotten from you guys is that he
can cry but he he has to know when to
cry and he and he can't cry too much and
if he cries too much he needs to so
that's too many slack caveats right
you're right I just gotta be able to cry
to you and you can't tell me what I can
cry about and how long I cry about if
you tell me I can be emotional to you
you don't get to tell me what I can be
emotional about this is why I just say
just don't cry bro Alex and cry to me
talking talking sorry just quickly so so
just talking about um early we're
talking about leadership and 50 50 and
bosses and this that and the other if
you're if you're a man and you cry
over you know not a loss or what I said
before
um to your partner
you've demonstrated
the the inability to be stable you've
demonstrated that you can't be trusted
you've demonstrated that you can't be a
leader you can't be followed because if
I'm if if you're be if you're being
followed and then it gets Peak and then
you're depressed or whatever the
situation is and you're crying
we don't see presidents crying like you
don't see leadership you don't see the
CEO of a company crying well unless it's
a woman but it doesn't mean she doesn't
because he doesn't because you don't see
it doesn't mean they're not crying no
you're right but that's what I'm saying
they don't do it in front of the people
they're Leading Men are saying wait wait
Matt wait men are supposed to lead women
so you don't you don't see the CEO going
to a company meeting and start crying
it's the same thing with like if you're
if you know I know some people do the 50
50 thing but if you want to be in a more
traditional relationship where you
follow the man you're with then he
shouldn't go to the people the person
he's leading and cry of course not I
wouldn't agree 100 understand your point
but I feel like she was saying like
you're allowed to be vulnerable
You're human and then it's time for you
to pick yourself up like I feel like in
a relationship depending on yours and
guys's you know boundaries obviously
like if you follow more traditional
methods and etc etc like you're allowed
to be vulnerable if your partner says
that's okay with you you can be
vulnerable for that time being and then
pick yourself up like it's cool yeah but
the whole point is wait the whole point
is that each girl is different and so
it's kind of like rolling the dice like
look at this from a guy's perspective
you know me I said every two years she
said you know you could do it three days
four days whatever whatever it is
everybody but wait but every girl is
different and so it's like for one girl
you know she might be okay with it this
long for another girl she might be okay
with it this long so it's like why risk
it even the ghosts that say it's okay
that sounds nice that sounds nice and
it's very emotionally intelligent and
it's beautiful though the girls don't
even know that they've lost something
for you
the attraction yeah they get the ick
whatever that thing is that made them
feel comfortable in your leadership or
your presence or your even partnership
whatever whatever that thing is they've
lost it they don't they didn't they
didn't even know it happened men
focused on your purpose
shoelace with a bunny ear bunny ear over
like a baby doesn't it and I'm just like
ick he's never coming near me so now you
see the problem we have right so like
it's it's it's it's
but why would he risk that like why
wouldn't he just say you know what in
general I'm gonna try not to cry in
front of her if it happens it happens
but in general unless it's super serious
I'm just I'm not gonna generally we all
have that rule like I don't walk into a
room expecting to be upset and cry I
just think if it happens it happens it's
just like you know if someone pees
themself you don't make a big deal
you're like go off of there
consume you realistically and that's
where communication comes in again you
can literally discuss this before you go
through it but the problem is women
don't know what they want I know exactly
but a woman that does and a woman that's
got her you know priority straight can
communicate that with a man and
obviously if that's not the case and
that's not the case yeah guys I just
quick question for the man do you think
women know what they want in general no
how many wait how many women have you
dated it was it over under 20 over under
oh okay okay over under so I'm just the
only reason because the the next
question is what type of women do you
date at least 20 that's a good sample
size do you think in general women know
what they want do you think they cap
about what they want yeah okay that's my
only point I'm not saying as a whole
they're like as in what every woman
wants or like I'm not saying I know what
I want but in terms of certain scenarios
and situations like I feel like I could
let a man confinding me and like let me
know when there's something up do you
know what I mean maybe I'm not saying
like all the time or like every single
day but like at least you know you can
tell me if there's something up whether
you cry or not I I understand what
you're saying and like I agree to some
extent but again it's like for them it's
a roll of the dice and they don't know
which girl is going to be turned off by
it and like sometimes a girl will say I
won't be but she'll still leave the
game's the game at the end okay that's
fine so
I've just I just I just sat here and I
literally didn't hear one person explain
to me what it was okay to cry up so all
I wanted to hear 100
of us earlier but like you can cry
exactly like Alex will say to me exactly
come to me try and I won't look at you
different but I haven't heard one person
say that it's about respect
communication consent and boundaries and
those are the four things that you need
to come into any relationship with it's
man man woman woman they them he X
whatever it is and if you feel like
you're in a place where you have to cry
so why is it okay if he's at that place
where he's about to break down he can
only come to you like there are lots of
other people on this planet that he
could should feel comfortable as long as
they're men but that's the thing exactly
but all right okay fair enough
um let's not let's say
biologically we are intrinsically
reactionary and just get the ick when
men cry right but you could still be my
friend you might not be tapping it there
are so many other ways I think it's just
if you cry to me you've cried and
there's no particular ick if you've
cried during sex maybe but like if if
you've cried because there's a general
reason that you're upset cool let's
let's talk about it I just I've been
through some really hard times in my
life yeah
and the one thing that I would never do
is let my mom see me cry let my mom see
me for my mom to see her son cry do you
know what I'll do to this Africa she
would actually contemplate her whole
existence about what's going on so a lot
of times us men we we have to keep
things together just for you guys
because by you seeing your man cry then
it can completely destroy everything and
that and that's just something that I
just take personally well I personally
go through life not expecting that so I
again like just say I'm so laid back
like like what are we doing like it's
not that deep
um okay I'm going to take a second to
read super chats and then we're going to
do final thoughts and you can guys can
plug any social media and we're going to
close out the show
um okay guys uh we have what 3 200
people watching so make sure you like
the video
um subscribe to the channel okay our
pain um it's none of your business your
it's none of your effing business where
we cry men do not cry over issues to
women PX shame on my dad died I couldn't
call it off my best dog I couldn't call
off my best dog on Christmas life is
real none of you women are over a five
silly sausage we just wanted not to not
have to read your mind if you want to
vent that's fine if you want a solution
perfectly fine just let us know which
before you rant about how Sarah's
boyfriend's cousin's niece is a slack
um c matherson um Pearl please buy a
neon sign that says men don't care about
your strong and your strong empowered
women with jobs I'm Daniel M they
appreciate logical and direct decision
making of a man but crucified China for
being logical and direct PS the woman in
the blue onesie is laying C matherson
these women are about to get replaced by
Brazilian and Filipino women
that's already started go follow
um
go
oh my God I can't remember the account
name but there's a guy that went to
Brazil and he's really good content
um Keith the chef we have been fed a lot
it's to break up the nuclear family um
the people who tax us get to tax us get
to keep the alphas who usually challenge
arbitrary Authority confused and busy
with chaos wake up Doug MPA if men win
everyone wins if women win women win
keep the chief it's our job as men to
train them weak men can't
um Keith the show Pearl is doing
everyone a favor do a us live show we
didn't know this is the female archetype
you saved my relationship because I Now
understand how she sees the world thank
you C matherson men can get an essay
claim or an essay claim just for looking
at a woman oh essay I get it
um a quick Bay on the on the point of
jobs we as men just cannot get up and
get better jobs whenever we want your
body count is a choice that you can
control tell 9265 dang autocorrect I
meant red dress the UK Economist would
the guests want their oh I read this
already Let me refresh it just make sure
there's no more Super chats and then
we'll close out the show like the video
guys subscribe to the channel okay woke
is Panther um why do women see men that
don't emote emote like women as being
cold and emotionless see matherson why
is it that women treat their men like
sub-human unless they want them crying
then suddenly he's a full-blown human
okay
um final thoughts any social media you
got you want to plug
um my social media is let me bring
closer my social media is pink Kush
that's my Instagram
um you can write it spell it as
p-i-n-k-u-s-h-e-m-zed so cushions on the
end
um I do a bit of everything I'm a social
creative person so yeah hit me up and my
final thoughts is that's just like
General
um yeah I feel like today was a very
good day overall and I met a lot of
different dynamics of peoples and I'm
grateful to be a part of such a you know
growing community
um my social media is bexie Lucy X and
my website is bexclucy.com I've got
ebooks and I also do coaching on
femininity and mindset and today
um it was good to hear different
opinions from different women I like to
listen to gain more knowledge
um but me personally I've agreed mostly
with what China and pearl said and my
goals at the moment are to find a
husband get married and it's not focused
on my career it's on making a family so
yeah when that time comes that's
what I'm ready for
hi so uh my Instagram is shorty Devi
which is
s-h-o-r-t-y-d-e-v-i underscore
um I'm a coach a life coach a conscious
parenting coach I help people uh live
their best lives basically
um thank you for having me here it's
been really interesting there have
definitely been some views that I
haven't agreed on but it's always really
interesting to have a healthy debate
about everything
um and yeah thanks
hey so my final thoughts terrifyingly is
that feminism might actually be dead
um I have a lot to think about
retrospectively after hearing a lot of
opinions that I thought were
maybe slightly outdated I feel a little
bit sad that women took such a bash this
evening for wanting to be leaders to do
Innovative things and to say and do what
they need to say and do without being
criticized for it so I think that women
make strong leaders men make strong
leaders it's how you wield that power
and my name is Cleo and I'm not really
on the social so I won't say it because
I left it specifically so that I could
have some peace then came on a podcast
so check me out but yeah okay hi Tanya
so
um same reason as can you make a Little
Closer
thank you
um same reason as Cleo
um
no socials at the moment for peaceful
reasons but I think today's just been
more observed so I just want to reflect
back on what everyone said and kind of
moving forward to see how I feel about
certain things
yeah um my name is Chuck so my name is
China the man named voice just thank you
to everybody that's come to the show
today it was a full cast um I really
enjoyed having hearing all you all the
different opinions and and things as
well
um yeah make sure you follow me on
socials at my name is China that's over
why on tick tock on Instagram I wanna
give a shout out to the obviously the
live of the chat guys uh it was Doug MP
and the rest of them like I really
appreciate it because uh my YouTube has
been getting more and the views are
getting more and that's happening
because of all of you guys I just wanted
to thank you and obviously always thank
Paul for having me on as a returning
guest yeah
uh final thoughts just thanks for having
me on the show
um haven't got any socials that I'd
necessarily want to share um but yeah I
really appreciated listening to like
diverse thought really
uh thank you pal thank you everyone
thank you all the people in the back
that you can't see thank you China thank
you to everybody
um social media Instagram sweet sweet
underscore juice and uh final four is
ah Pullman
um so my name is Jasmine Bruce on all
platforms realistically j-a-z
m-i-n-e-b-r-u-c-e
um final thoughts realistically I'm glad
to hear in one of the comments that um
it this has helped
um hear different views and stuff and
really changed them
um so I'm glad to hear that and just
want to say thank you for having me
yeah
final thoughts um I want to reiterate
one of the super chats that said
when men win
men and women win when the woman wins
the woman wins I just want to reiterate
that because we skipped over that too
quickly we need to take that one in
um
go and check out 100 interviews on
YouTube go and follow the socials
109 underscores because that's what I
could find and then the word percent
okay love
hi guys thanks for having me my name is
Jess I'm on Instagram
um I do r b music you can follow me um
it's Jessica k-u-k-a with another a on
the end so yeah run that up and thanks
guys for having me I think it's healthy
to talk about these things because you
know everyone's got different opinions
so it's it's refreshing to hear I'd say
um we had one or two more Super chats
and final thoughts so qdub a woman's job
is to put you in a compromising or to
put you in a compromising position to
found out find out if she has the best
guy don't cry if you do so it must be an
emergency only um Estelle ascella my man
cried in front of me and we had the best
night ever four years I have never seen
him down this one got me to melt and
love him more woke his Panther why do
women oh I read that okay okay
um thank you guys for liking the video
um let's get 3 000 likes on this video
um we had over 3000 people in the chat
so I think we should have at least three
thousand likes a couple announcements
before we end the show um the first is
that we have two clips channels just
pearly clips and pearl daily make sure
you go subscribe to both sign up for our
membership tears the first you get to be
a part of our live chat welcome to the
new members that joined the show second
you get to be a part of our Discord and
our Vlogs
um if you guys want to see me freestyle
yeah yes yeah no not now on the Vlog on
the on the Vlog ten dollars a month sign
up
yeah behind the scenes blog and um third
you get to connect with me on social
media this means having access to my
inbox and fourth um you get a one-on-one
call with me once a month these are
great because you can get help with
YouTube
um doing the live show is a lot of work
and I can help you avoid a lot of
problems that I had when I started a
live show so if you want the blueprint
of how to start a live show
um I know it so sign up for that tier
follow on my Instagram they banned my
first one so just pearly things one is
my new Instagram go follow my fifth and
sixth tick tocks because they've been my
first four just probably things top five
and just probably things six subscribe
to wife school also you have to look at
my community posts or maybe someone put
it in the chat but I have a new channel
and I'm gonna start doing Reactions
where I have like show guests come over
and we'll hang out and do reactions it's
just gonna be like it's called Pearl
behind the scenes and it's just
basically going to be us
reacting to different content maybe
freestyling a little bit I don't know
we'll see
um subscribe to the channel on your way
out like the video and